so i'm calling shenanigans they still
haven't called the race for kerry lake
yo last night we were waiting for the
primary results out of arizona you guys
know that we've had carrie lake on the
show several times she's she's amazing
and uh i saw the the uh the the polling
results as they were coming in and i was
shocked to see that carrie lake was down
in the polls i was like how is this
possible
everybody was like nah she's gonna win
she's gonna win and then i was like well
what can you do go to bed wake up boom
carrie lake in the lead 80 reporting and
carrie lake and her team they've
declared victory
now
analysts are saying in all likelihood it
really does seem like she can't lose
there she's up around 11 000 or so votes
and it looks like the remaining votes
that are going to come in aren't going
to pull enough for uh her opponent to
win
but something strange is happening with
uh how it's being handled
and there is a a an interesting uh
solution to this conundrum
democrats have reportedly been been
crossing over and voting in the gop
primary when you look at the results
right now you can see maricopa is is
against carrie or i should say it's for
robson her opponent and that's the dense
democrat area if they're coming out and
voting in the gop primary that's what
you would see so we'll talk about that
we'll talk about what's going on and why
they haven't called the race yet for
kerry lake and then we got i guess
in international news russia says
they're going to join china if a war
breaks out between china and the us over
taiwan china is going to be firing
missiles over taiwan the first time ever
and surrounding it with live fire drills
and military uh
ships
you know i i really do think that it's
possible
i think it's probable nancy pelosi went
to taiwan because they expect taiwan to
fall and fall soon
so we'll talk about that before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member to
support our work as a member you get
access to our exclusive members only
show which will come up tonight at 11 pm
tim cast irl members only uncensored as
well as our other shows that we have
like tales from the inverted world and
soon to be cast castle with your support
we're going to be doing a whole lot of
really awesome stuff with new shows and
i want to stress that we have taken
paypal off the website when you sign up
now you are supporting parallel economy
that's the name of the company it's
called parallel economy parallel
academy.com dan bongino co-founded this
company censorship resistant financial
transactions we have seen people be
de-banked banned from their bank
accounts for their opinions i don't
stand for that so we we immediately were
like we gotta we gotta get parallel
economy we have to support the systems
that will allow people free speech and
we have to reject the systems that are
shutting everybody down so when you sign
up at timcast.com you're not only
supporting us you're supporting parallel
economy you're supporting rumble
infrastructure so don't forget smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us today to talk about all this
we got libby libby's back hey i'm back
i'm libby evans i'm editor-in-chief with
the post-millennial glad to be here
right on and we got hannah claire hi i'm
hannah brimley i'm a writer for
timcast.com
hey everyone ian crossland here in
crossland.net happy to be here
lydia is not with us today because she's
on vacation and i'm chris filling in for
lydia nice jacket that was the fastest
we've ever done in introductions on this
on this show i just want to talk about
nancy pelosi
oh nancy pelosi no we're gonna talk
about carrie like first but
oh good
all right we have this story from axios
phoenix
lake declares victory in arizona gop
primary says outstanding ballots will
favor her with at least 150 000 votes
left to count carrie lake declared
victory wednesday in the republican
primary for governor while rival karen
taylor robson stayed mum throughout the
day
lake led robson by less than two
percentage points and as of wednesday
morning but the remaining ballots which
are largely early ballots that were
dropped off at polling places on
election day are expected to expand her
lead
okay i say the ap hasn't called the race
yet but look
even though their their early ballots
they're still saying it's likely gonna
be for carrier lake but let me show you
this uh let me see if i have the maps
here check this out did we just get an
update i think we just got an update
literally right now
still that's still eighty percent it's
been eighty percent
new york times they've been calling it
80 all day yeah take a look at this
right here we can see taylor robson in
the in maricopa she's got it but the
rest of the state is for kerry lake how
is it this close
i think there's a simple answer
democrats are voting as republicans in
the in the republican primary
it's certainly possible i mean why not
do a crossover but then they're not
going to be able to vote democrat in the
democratic party the democrat primary
was today too and if
you scroll up if you look at the
democrat primary um what do i say katie
hobbs yeah katie hobbs had
all of the state except for was it santa
cruz county there at the bottom santa
cruz county yeah that's it so it's not
like there was a big contentious race on
the democrat side some of you were gonna
yeah
it's a question of like if you they
think it's more effective to try and put
a more extreme candidate in office we've
all talked about this they think that
they can beat carrie lake later
you know
these notes yeah it's a better gamble to
uh
vote in the republican primary i guess i
mean not all states have open primaries
like this and some if you're registered
as a democrat you can only participate
in the democratic primary that's true in
new york yeah new york stream
connecticut nevada i think is changing
this law and the idea because they're
talking about like a rank choice
right choice voting yeah we have ranked
choice voting in new york in new york
city but um you can still only vote in
your
designated party primary oh yeah
with these people if they
now
like are they still registered democrat
while they're voting in the republican
primary you have to change your
registration most likely can they do
that like and then the next day change
it back or are they stuck it for a year
as like a republican now
i i don't know what the rules are about
registering that's like such local stuff
i don't know yeah there's huge varieties
some places you have to
be registered for a certain period of
time prior to like before you know who
the candidates are no they've known who
the candidates are for a long time
carrie lake was running for governor
starting in january so i think they i
think you probably could have changed it
before it's an open primary oh it's an
open priority so even if they're
registered as a democrat they can
participate in the republican primary
wow that's kind of crazy maybe we
shouldn't allow that yeah i don't know
that why would you have that right the
argument against it is or the argument
against it is typically that
independents can't participate in the
primary so nevada has a high proportion
of independent voters and they think
leaving the closed primary system would
be better because they would have they
would be able to participate in
narrowing down the candidates earlier on
take a look at this over at the new york
times article you can see 482 113 votes
in the democratic primary
637 thousand 210 in the republican party
but for some reason
it's the
maricopa area that's gone for karen
taylor robson and not kerry lake
maybe it's crossover i'm not entirely
convinced it may just be
moderate leaning republicans are like
where do i want the maga stuff so that's
probably true yeah right in the cities
they're more
moderates yeah i mean but are these
people going to come out for pence isn't
he talking about making iran though
i don't know about that he's the
milkiest of the milk toasts you know but
i'll i'll add this
if these numbers are correct and that at
637 000 republicans came out to vote
democrats are in serious trouble serious
trouble
if it's true that democrats switched
over because we've seen that reported in
certain in other instances then
republicans are going to be blindsided
because if how many how many of these
would you need to take away you take
away a hundred thousand of these votes
and then all of a sudden the democrats
are winning yeah or not quite or yeah
actually they would be winning i don't i
don't believe that a hundred thousand
people came out and were democrats
voting to sabotage carry a lake it's
possible i think it's probably just
simply put
urban conservative types are middle of
the road but i thought we might have
heard and we might have seen like the
you know arizona democratic party making
the suggestion people aren't good at
keeping these kind of secrets so if it
was a suggestion
we would have seen it on social media
i mean look megan mccain's got fans and
she was ripping into carrie lagoon she
was so mad about it but the other thing
is that i pulled the real clear politics
poll numbers i mean carrie lake has been
popular she has been leading the polls
for several weeks at this point so in
some ways you know maybe people did
cross over and on the other hand you
would assume there'd be some indication
that she is maybe more popular than
arizona is willing to admit to itself
well that that makes sense i mean if
they're polling people you get a phone
call and you're like who are you voting
for someone who hates carrie lake is
gonna be like not carrie lake but
someone who's crossing over to sabotage
carrie lee like will contribute to a
vote against her so
you know if if they get called up it's a
democrat are you voting for karen taylor
robson they're saying no way
but they do vote in the primary to
sabotage league that someone could be
i'm a democratic registered democrat but
i'm going to vote in the republican
primary for the crappier candidate and
then i'm going to switch back and vote
for the democratic
but this is an open this is an open
primary take a look at this story so i
guess can you if it's an open primary
can you show up and say you want one
ballot instead of another or is
everybody on the same ballot i don't
know that would be weird how would they
prevent you from voting twice it could
explain why a bunch of uh well here's
the other issue too
now
this is the weird thing people are
pointing out like it's very strange that
carrie lake was doing so well in the
polls
what about every other candidate in in
arizona look at this blake masters
wins swimmingly
so all of these trump endorsed
candidates
sweep through with no questions
but then carrie lake is
and it's not just about arizona it's
like all these states gibbs in michigan
i think it's michigan right trump
endorsed wins with the help from
democrats a lot of help from democrats
that was so weird that was so
interesting because they were
putting in money
democrats were putting money in to get
gibbs the victory there and this is the
strategy
um this is a strategy i was listening to
this podcast today the new york times
podcast actually um about how claire
mccaskill was the one who really
pioneered this strategy of essentially
picking the candidate that she wanted to
run against
and then
putting like putting up ads that made
that candidate popular to the far right
so she looked at the spate of candidates
in missouri
um decided that she wanted to run
against this one guy
who seemed crazy who eventually ended up
being the one who said that if a woman
is raped she can shut that down and then
not get pregnant remember that guy yeah
yeah everybody have a wave has a way of
shutting that down right because of
course sure you know every woman knows
that you've got like a trap door yeah
this is a basic human biology i don't
know what you guys think
you know
for some guys those medieval monks were
correct with the teeth you know you can
shut it down is that what that sorry you
remember the medieval month i remember
yeah yeah
sounds awesome you guys we were in a
different health lesson by gender i did
see that movie teeth
oh god no have you ever seen it oh
actually i in a play that i wrote this
one time uh one of the characters how
are we talking about this now
anyway this
is one character she said if i had teeth
down there i'd have bit his hand off
have you ever there's a movie called tv
please
and they're like this woman goes to the
doctor to like the gyno and he's like
let me just check you up and then his
hand gets mutilated and he's like vagina
dantata
there's like
and then she's like
yeah that's the movie it's like i guess
a horror movie i had a friend who was
obsessed with that and he also would
that's a totally different story anyways
it was claire mccaskill
she she went with this thing uh and she
was running ads that was like you know
this person is really opposite and she
made him really popular to the far right
and that is a strategy that they used to
to pump gibbs and also we all remember
when trump was running against hillary
clinton and everyone was like oh it'll
be great if trump gets the gop
nomination because hillary clinton will
have no trouble beating him you know
this is a stupid this is a stupid
maneuver guys you know like go with your
values
let's make sure you try and run people
you believe in who you would think would
be positive and good leaders for our
country absolutely not no that's against
the rules november of 2016 one of the
greatest years ever was just seeing the
establishment
have everything implode
the panic the crying it was insane it
was it was like
schadenfreude but just like uh like the
most
dense
hyper-concentrated straight into the
vein
intravenous schadenfreude watching all
these people lose their minds i will say
i was one of the sad people and i went
to
whole foods no i went to fairway i went
to fairway in brooklyn the next day
which is this like extremely yuppy
grocery store
and there were people crying like
sobbing as they were picking out their
frozen vegan waffles and then sweet home
alabama came on like over the pa system
and this older woman walked up to like
one of the people who worked there and
said now i really think this is in very
poor taste can we at least change this
my stella has a story about dropping her
kids off at montessori like school or
whatever and these moms sobbing and one
is like does someone have a snack to
give to jim like i did i couldn't pack
one this morning you're like girl get it
together yeah it feels like you know you
can still feed your kids but i remember
people calling out of work with with
like sadness just calling like i mean
going into morning it was crazy but i
remember yeah i was just having a good
time yeah it was wild cassandra
banks what was going on yeah cause i was
crying but for the other she was yeah
tears of drawing of joy so you know i
was hanging out with her and it's just
it's it's fun to reminisce about some of
the greatest days in human history right
but uh november 2nd 2016. it's one of
those was it no it was it was the 11th
was it no it's ninth it was the ninth
what when they what do you mean november
9th is when trump won was seven
it was sunday it was early november we
can agree it was before the 15th cold
day
november 8th
there we go number eight everybody's
wrong i'm happy no but the ninth was
when they called it for him
the ninth is when he was young
they did declare after midnight so tim
is technically correct here he's like
i'm talking about everybody crying it's
november 9th yeah
uh okay so i'll take technically correct
but it reminds me of that meme where the
two women go like
and the guy just goes yeah
you know what i'm talking about there's
like two women and they look at
something and they're like shocked and
the guy just starts laughing and smiling
that's what it was like i didn't vote
for him but it was just like to see
hillary clinton just see everything that
she's ever wanted taken from her and
she's such a just an awful person it was
just wilderness it was so amazing it
just it was euphoria you know yeah i was
it was totally crazy i remember how many
people around me were just
like it was completely divided as what i
remember even people who weren't that
political were suddenly like i don't
know what's gonna happen to the country
and the people i had no idea were in any
way interested in politics also being
like this is the best thing ever like
well so i had no idea so bringing it
back to where we are now with you know
like carrie lake and all that stuff now
i'm just like okay look you know i voted
for trump in 2020 i think school choice
was really really important he was all
about it and looking now at arizona with
kerry lake um
the possibility is that the whole system
is just is completely imploded
yeah like democrats so look the atlanta
general constitution wrote democrats are
voting in gop primaries say it's all
about donald trump this article talks
about how was it 16 000 voters who chose
democratic ballots were among the 237
who voted in the gop primary now it's
possible i argued they just switched
parties they've abandoned the democrats
that's a reality right maybe what we're
seeing in arizona is that tons of
democrats are like i don't want the
democrats i don't want the maga and so
there are they are legitimately trying
to vote republican and it's just it's
left more left-leaning people joining
the republican party
the same time
democrats are funding trump-supported
trump endorsed candidates so the
democratic officials are are propping up
trump's endorsed candidates while the
voters are voting for the other moderate
republican candidate or whatever they
want to call him it's just the whole
system is busted oh we watched it no go
ahead oh it's just like larry hogan got
really mad about this too he was like
democrats are funny i mean it was like
what one point it was like over a
million dollars for 1.2 million or
something right and they got funded in
and he was like this is democrat
interference in our election like this
this is not good and i
don't
think that it matters to them like even
if the strategy is you could argue what
got donald trump elected which i don't
think it is but it played a role in some
part in some ways it's not working for
them i don't understand why you would
keep doing it well we did watch them
change the rules right like it was after
the 2016 election and we watched
everyone freak out because trump had won
and decide that this was a huge crisis
and that now it didn't matter what you
had what what you did so long as you
were resisting remember resist and it
was like
i remember watching that and i was like
resist what though you guys like what is
it that we are going to resist
or like with obama change well what do
you want to change really and what do
you want to change it to like define
your terms so that we can actually talk
about what's going on but with the whole
resist thing it was anything trump
anything trump did was completely wrong
and had to be stopped at all costs
remember that and they proceeded that
way through now i had friends tell me
that using like violent fascist
tendencies against your enemy if trump
for whatever was fine i'm like dude
that's insane right you cannot take on
evil and become evil to destroy evil
just creating more but that's what
that's the decision that was made was
that this is a crisis rules don't matter
common decency doesn't matter we have to
give up every the ways that we've
behaved up to this point you know that
was what they did i'm just so tired of
you all the people that cried
when donald trump won
those the people that i'm i'm just i i
am sick of and and you know like tucker
crosston pointed out when uh i think it
was ben smith asked if he was racist
that was a great interview yeah he was
like the people that i don't like are
like middle-aged white liberal women
he's like i blamed him for everything
yeah he's like that's the one that's not
racist
um
that they are an overwhelming major
an overwhelmingly large block of
democrat voters so you look at this
group they're crying they have no idea
what they're crying about oh the mean
man said naughty words dude when you've
got
murderous dictators communist regimes
outright fascists are they called trump
fascists but come on he's not and
they're actually threatening us
you might want the potty mouth bully guy
to go in there and you know shove
someone around and be like back off i
that was a thing i liked about trump you
know trump is as i've said before he's
the crazy guy on a corner with a knife
you stay away from them
you you keep your distance your house
never gets right it's okay
like all of all of the buildings on the
street are just like vandalized and
looted but there's one really nice one
yours is fine and they're just like how
come no one's robbing this building it
was a crazy guy on the corner with a
knife i just keep feeding them steaks
it's fine it works out one way to keep
on like when he said he was going to
nuke beijing or moscow do you remember
that and nobody and you don't know he
might
he just might that's the thing with
biden now right like biden is a dotty
old man and you have absolutely no
confidence that he's going to do
anything other than the most moderate
conciliatory
uh weak-ass move
yeah i think he'll just be totally in
line i mean
i don't mean to kick him while he's down
but like this guy got coveted after just
getting coded like i don't really think
though he doesn't know anything so he's
no idea he's like signing executive
orders while locked in his bedroom he's
grounded like i
i don't know that uh
sometimes when we talk about biden like
will he run for re-election what i
actually think has happened is he's
going to forget that he was told he
wasn't so he's going to announce that he
is and they're going to have to be he's
going to he said that he was going to
he's going to forget that he's president
and there's going to be like remember
when he announced he was running for the
senate while he was running for
president yeah and hasn't he called both
hasn't he called jill biden or his wife
the president at one point several times
he kept calling her the president
several times and he and he introduced
his sister as his wife yeah but he's the
dude's got to be on some kind of pills
like i bet they're giving him all this
crazy iv therapy stuff they're putting
them in hyperbaric like regeneration
chambers they're like we must but what's
gonna happen is come 2024 he's gonna be
like what am i what am i doing and
they're like you're retired it's like oh
and then they're going to walk out be
buddha judge your new son and be like
come on get in there right and then
they're going to yeah or aoc yeah i hope
so i really hope it's aoc she is so dumb
though you guys
i mean maybe ignorance
is letting us in on a secret yeah still
learning i don't think that she's
ignorant i think she's i think she's
just not that bright really yeah she
strikes me as in every time she speaks
about things she strikes you as a
television have you ever watched she
puts her glasses on and she looks she
sits up straight like it's good it's
good move maybe she's just maybe it's
more charisma than intelligence she's
got she's got spunk yeah she's she's so
new i mean she says stuff that isn't
true like that's right so that's more
ignorance like if she doesn't know stuff
no it's stupid it is i think was it
sheamus who said it was a total chad
move when she went on colbert just made
up stuff about this
crazy i mean that's that's ballsy you
know so the thing about aoc
is that i kind of view her similarly
similarly to trump and that it would be
like chaotic for the deep state and i'm
down for that it's not my preferred
candidate but if you if it was aoc
versus trump i'm kind of like whoever
wins the establish the bureaucratic
state is going to be crying into their
pillow tonight do you think would win
i think trump would win but trump would
i do think aoc is the democrats best
choice like their best bet she's got
name recognition she's young
she's like she's got 13 million
followers not the most prominent
particularly prominent but gavin newsom
he's like a he's like plastic he's he's
a he's generic one of the things they've
been saying they don't want you know
yeah he's just like an established
white kind of you know he's younger than
let's say bernie sanders but one thing
he definitely has against him is a lot
of data to back up why he sucks
you know his schools are failing his
state is failing
he's an abortion sanctuary state he
constantly brings back coveted
regulations he's an immigrant um
illegal immigrant sanctuary state right
he's an immigrant no yeah i did but
that's because i left out words
yeah yeah i understand um he messed he
like violated all his own cove
restrictions remember those like no
one's gonna forget those dinners at
french laundry yeah
really not wearing masks
with his friends i think if aoc were to
get elected
her whole thing is like attention social
media saying whatever it would be pure
it would be pandemonium
just just insanity in the white house
they would be coming to her being like
president ocasio-cortez here here's the
documents on the latest problem that's
happening in afghanistan and then she's
going to say something totally unrelated
or relevant she's going to be like you
know when we went into afghanistan in
2005 in desert storm the first time you
had saddam hussein who was working with
isis and you know that's why i don't
think it's a good idea and they're going
to be like she's just saying random
things related to the middle east either
that or yeah either that or she'll just
be like we can't go to war with that
country because that would be racist
wait i'll take it yeah you know it's
like no more troops in the middle east
because president aoc says it's settler
colonialism i'll be like okay all right
like no foreign incursions
i don't care the reason i mean i am kind
of worried about that at the federal
level and then the weirdly isolationist
because she's like no we just have to
leave everyone else alone and then the
first gentleman will be a guy with the
page on foot wiki right like
the redhead dude yeah why he does well
they i don't know for sure but remember
they were going after his feet when he
wore sandals when they went to florida
to flout covered restrictions and have a
good time
so that was you just want to date me
that was like her right
that was her whole thing and it was all
like and her boyfriend was sitting there
with yeah just i'm just imagining she's
like sitting down with kim jong-un and
he's like you know kim jong-un says
something about we have to negotiate
terms if i'm going to stop these nuclear
tests and she goes stop trying to date
me sir and then he's just like
what do i say it's almost as crazy as
trump
so like the americans have put a crazy
person in the white house again yeah i
don't know what she wants but they
couldn't they can't now we
zag the other way with crazy like it's
different kind of crazy they can't
figure that one out either i mean that
is kind of funny it's like trump is
aggressive arrogant kind of crazy and
she's like
woman kind of crazy or also arrogant
kind of crazy but like that you want to
date me line it's like trump would never
say something like that like i don't
think a dude would be like yeah kim
jong-un was trying to date me like he
wouldn't i also think she knows like
it's a very awkward thing for most men
to respond to like they can say no but
also like why are you making this about
romance like we're professional rivals
like we're in politics like why are you
bringing this up like it's very strange
women women can make everything about
romans
that's what the girls wanted him to grab
them by uh their genitals
yeah that was a little romantic though
well
for guys it was different you know yeah
i mean it's a type of romance he only
said that because he never heard about
no that's not that's
arrows yeah that's erotic uh-huh
it's love you know it's love
that's true lost
i i highly i would love to see cortez
over trump because of the youth it's the
youth over trump over trump i can't take
80 year olds in in office anymore man
they're right
i'm trying to be ageist but it is really
frustrating to see
uh our parents my parents generation
just refuse to give up power you know
they're just sitting there on piles of
cash and piles of power and they refuse
to
clear the way for somebody else and it's
their fault it's it's and all of the
mess is their fault and it's like you
know we definitely need new people in
in washington this is one thing i like
about desantis like he's young he's like
you know isn't he gen x basically
i don't know
um i think he's i think he's like 45.
he's like low-end he's like let's say at
most 50 he's got young children he
hasn't gotten he's in his 40s
that's awesome wow right so let's go get
it desantis over aoc if we could i'd
like to see the debate i'll be honest
that's something to my jury's out for me
on that but i would love to tell you
guys debate a trump aoc debate would be
the funniest show i've ever seen
and they'd keep doing amazing excuse me
excuse me young lady no no crazy aoc and
then she'd be like trump just likes me
he thinks i'm hot it would just be the
weirdest thing
stephen stephen fry should be the
moderator of that debate can we really
really
make that happen can i can i i'm going
to i want to reach out to asu's people
like would you do it put it on your
vision for trump yeah even if they're
going to make a vision board of trump
debating aoc and then we're going to try
and make it happen wish it into reality
several years ago was saying on twitter
that was like after trump is done with
politics like he should just and like
when the next presidential debates
happen he should just live stream him
commenting on them because it's probably
more interesting because like him
watching him debate is so bizarre
like i i there's nothing that compares
to it really bringing aoc into it like
we're sitting here talking about like
how funny it would be for aoc to like
debate or haven't have like a show like
be on a show with trump and then
imagining how it would backfire and
sort of backfire on us and that they end
up agreeing on tons of populist
positions and then like trump runs with
aoc as vp
he's like we're gonna win everyone she's
like i was wrong about this man we're
gonna get the union working class
manufacturing back it'll never happen
because it's not really the case but
i'm gonna i'm gonna it would be nice to
get manufacturing back yeah yeah i mean
it was happening under trump yeah i'll
say this i
i will say with certainty
i believe donald trump would absolutely
do i sit down with aoc
100 probably i mean i don't think
ratings would be great and she loves
ratings you know yeah she had nothing to
lose she wouldn't do it that'd be good
combo they don't even have to agree or
disagree they just talk about ideas you
don't think she'd do it i don't think so
i don't think i think we should i think
we should reach out there's only one way
for us to find out tim has to reach out
i expect you to be on twitter tonight
you know we've got
some of uh
trump's like inner circle's been on the
show yeah so we'll ask them
because they they've told us like you
know we could arrange a sit down with
donald trump but it means we have to go
to him and it certainly would not be a
two and a half hour show but that's you
know i was saying like we'll have trump
on as long as he wants to be on it would
be an honor and a privilege and then
just whenever he's done we can shake his
hand and say thanks for coming and then
you know carry out the show like we do
normally we had joe rogan on the show
yeah for like an hour he was on longer
than i thought he was gonna use he said
he could pop in for a few minutes he
hung out for like an hour i'd be totally
down i just
i mean if it's up in new jersey i mean
maybe aoc could come down and do it you
know maybe we do it at a venue or
something where it's like kind of you
know her security can bring her in and
make sure she's safe and trumps people i
don't know if they i don't know if he'd
want to go to a venue though he'd be
like pull the chairs up to where i'm at
it would be the coolest thing in the
world though to be honest with you bring
them here it's a neutral ground they can
all have their security it'll be never
going to happen
yes but i can dream he's got that the
golf course in new jersey doesn't he so
this is what we were told is basically
we'd have to go up to bedminster sure to
uh if we were to do anything with trump
and then like is aoc going to drive down
there or whatever it's like that's not
that far
i mean
i'll tell you i don't think uh aoc
the one person that i know would
probably just say yes outright is vosh
if i if we hit him up we were like would
you like to sit down with donald trump
he'd be like yes please
just and you know so i'll give him
credit for be willing to do that despite
the things we disagree on i don't think
there's very many leftists at all that
would actually sit down and and have
like a calm recent debate and and you
know what's crazy about that is that
i mean trump was an anti-war president
right like the democrats for a long time
talked about being anti-war it's clear
that they're not obviously you know as
they court conflict with china and
russia at the same time
because that's apparently brilliant
diplomacy um
but yeah i don't
so many of trump's positions
like
well mostly just the anti-war one but
that's a classical
position you can you can you can
criticize him a lot for potty mouth
stuff
decorum whatever but his foreign policy
stuff was the best i've ever seen in my
lifetime i thought the bilateral
agreement thing was smart and i also
another another leftist position of his
or her liberal position of his is to
have union manufacturing in the u.s to
keep things local to keep americans
employed to keep ourselves
self-sufficient these used to be liberal
positions
yeah yeah they used to be and then
donald trump ran as a conservative he
supported gay marriage before getting
into office and i think he broke the
left because they were like what do we
campaign on now
he's he he went middle of the road
vox.com in 2015 i think it was 2015 or
16 said donald trump's a moderate he's
he's a moderate candidate now it's
really funny to see that if you go back
and look it up because i'm like the
media called him worse than hitler yeah
right but back then they're like he's a
moderate he was moderate in policy but
extreme in personality and that was
something they couldn't look past
well and really he's like sort of a
working-class hero
their decision making is based on
emotion
that's that's that's simply put so when
donald trump gets up there and he goes
you know like oh you know fat pig or you
know only rosie o'donnell they're like
and everyone else is just like
and a lot of people are just like oh
geez
okay but but do the right thing with
with the border okay how about that
that's the thing too about carrie lake
i think
you got she's even got biden basically
bending the knee onto this policy biden
is going to be repairing gaps in the
border and like humans yuma
look man
that's why i'm like why haven't they
called it for carrie lake because if
even joe biden agrees on the policy that
the arizona border is in trouble
that carrie lake's like whole thing is
like we gotta fix the border or one of
our big things well joe biden just
started re started rebuilding a border
wall yeah right he's he's building a
wall but he was like they and what was
that cringe on pierre was like it's not
trump's border wall we're just doing
what's necessary oh okay
but there was a building a wall there
was a democrat when you when you saw all
the coverage of the yuma stuff come out
at least my experience uh it was saying
you know this was a sector that had
previous funding but joe biden repealed
it and now he's going to fix these gaps
and basically there was one i can't
remember his name i have to look it up a
democratic arizona i think congressman
who was like i i just spoke to uh
president joe biden about this two weeks
ago and we're really gonna fix it now
and he is running for reelection right
now like
it is clear to everyone that the border
is out of control
yeah let's i want to jump to this nancy
pelosi foreign policy stuff but you know
because i was just thinking
we have a story from newsweek russia
blasts provocative pelosi and vows to
back china you even had a lawmaker in
russia say that if world war iii breaks
out they're gonna nuke london right away
and i'm just thinking about with all
this talk of president aoc
i wonder what china and russia are
thinking because in all in all
seriousness you know they're looking at
their calendars thinking
what's going to happen come 2025 when a
new administration enters what
opportunities do we lose what
opportunities do we gain what must we do
now i'll tell you what they're all
thinking the government of russia and
china what they're begging and hoping
for the united states would fight itself
that's what they want that's right well
we're doing a good job of that that's
the only way we could lose in this
situation
more than 27 likely of a loss would be
because of an internal conflict if so i
think if donald trump wins in 2024 china
is worried about that because they're
they're gutting our economy they're
they're extracting our resources and our
jobs
russia is excited about it because
donald trump does not want this this
psychotic american empire bs happening
in the middle east and russia's like
good for us it's probably why they
backed off from ukraine because they
felt like they weren't being threatened
by this expansionist you know uniparty
democrat republican garbage but china
would probably freak out but i'm
wondering if like
let's say the polls are wrong
let's say the democrats are voting in
the republican primary and so there's
more democrats voting and then aoc gets
elected
maybe not even aoc because that's very
silly right but
elizabeth warren who do we like no i i
just mean
there's
there's only one president i think out
of anyone
out of uh name a democrat name a
republican donald trump is the only
person i think who can handle the
foreign policy
with the conflict the crisis two reasons
one what we saw with this foreign policy
was the best i've ever seen in my
lifetime getting our troops out of the
middle east scheduling it to a great
degree pulling troops out eliminating
isis
crossing to the dmz into north korea
with no security detail was a huge sign
of good faith
abraham accords that was what was the
peace agreement up in europe which
country was it i always forget anyway
what like the kosovo was it no what was
it i don't know uh i don't know someone
want to look it up he did he did another
piece of agreement i'm sure the chat
will we'll know but the point is the
chat knows ella they do they do it's the
oracle it's the great work uh donald
trump's foreign policy was was just
downright the best on top of that he had
this this this twitching eye about
nuking his enemies if they crossed us so
you got the best of both worlds which
was great i love that part he's bringing
our troops back and nobody's crossing us
because he's got his finger right on the
nuke button being like i'm pulling my
troops out
you see and they're like looking at his
finger on the button they're like we're
not moving like get your troops out
we're fine
but joe biden
man this guy comes in and russia was
like okay into ukraine we go here we go
yeah yep well because biden's not going
to do anything everything he's going to
do is going to be calm and measured and
considerate you know he's never going to
take any real decisive action
yeah i think that was like the
that's the europe war area you know
that's what i was thinking yeah must be
over that's their battleground that's
like where they've been you know
hiding the dead bodies and everything
yikes right they had the mass graves
really under clinton it was horrible
kosovo yeah that whole area
so we got this after the velvet after
the velvet revolution we got these
stories you know russia says they're
going to back china china is going to
launch missiles over taiwan a russian
lawmaker said they would nuke london
he's like that's the first thing hit and
he said it's because london basically is
an epicenter for nato it's a huge so
they would go right after it i don't
know i think i think there's a lot of
saber rattling but how much of this is
us just being like naive and thinking
nothing bad could ever happen that it is
i think that there's a lot of naivety to
that and i think that we saw that under
the obama administration as well because
what happened with obama is he would
walk into the room having already stated
what compromises he would make right
because obama walks in he's like i'm a
reasonable man these are reasonable
provisions
okay except everyone else you're dealing
with is crazy invading lunatic right who
wants more territory who's not playing
by your new rules obama was playing by
the rules of we're in charge everyone's
cool with us being in charge we'll make
some consul you know considerations for
you we'll do some compromising biden's
going with those same rules and those
rules don't apply first of all he's
ridiculous and everybody knows it and
it's obvious any time he talks to world
leaders that everyone thinks that he's
you know lost his marbles
it's almost like a get well go broke
right and almost with the united states
like what happens is i'm imagining
you've got like a candy shop
and a security guard gets hired to stop
shoplifters and he's this six foot four
orange guy
who's just like looking at everybody
being like hey you fat pig you get out
of here hey i'm looking at you and
people are laughing some people are like
i don't want to go to this candy shop
anymore then the owner or like the the
investors come in and they're like
get this guy out of here and just get
anyone else and so they wheelchair in
this old man who's just sitting there
going
and then everyone runs in and starts
just looting the store
so
it's it's like
because of the potty mouth
they cancel the president and then say
we'll take anything else and you get
this tepid pathetic old man and now we
are being just rampaged over
internationally and it's not just
internationally right it's not just
internationally i mean there's like a
dwayne reed in new york that's been
putting spam in plastic lock boxes no
for real for real because of shoplifting
i mean we're you know we're destroying
our country we're destroying ourselves
on the world stage we're destroying our
reputation we're not doing these things
well obama who was it was saying i i
looked it up the other day because i
thought it was obama who was saying that
we had to manage the decline of the u.s
he didn't say it quite like that um he
said something like i think we've got to
blow up kids too many of them
but he said you know there was something
about that managing the decline of the
us and i don't know why we ever let
ourselves get sucked into that mindset
if we're going to be an empire why not
just take over more stuff because the
new world order needs to set in the old
world order is
limited war american military bases all
over the earth the liberal internet but
meanwhile everyone else is still playing
like they're empire builders i got an
idea for a video game
that i would like to make
and it's you're playing as obama
and you're droning kids yikes because
you know like well but but the democrats
supported him they think he was the
greatest president so what's the problem
like show his face and then it you see
and it zooms into his eye and then all
of a sudden you're looking at the camera
of the drone or strike they're not kids
you think they're kids but they're
demons
and then obama's like only i can do it
there are demons but the kids are there
as collateral but you still have to go
for the demons so it's like well the
kids are just in the way
i did not like obama i i mostly obama's
voice if if we do this video game then
you have to it's not actually a good
obama impression it's like an
exaggerated fire uh
away blop kids
he was the opposite of trump in that i
mean they were definitely different guys
but he was like likable personality but
pretty overrun by by the deep state and
militaristic he was blowing kisses while
pressing the drone strike super militant
he wasn't invading countries he was just
bombing stuff like you and they all have
been really even trump escalated the
bombing the drone bombing program in
secret and he gave the control to the
generals to make the decisions without
him it's just kind of commander
recently too like because we have we
have a uh don't we have a recruitment
failure right now in our military we
have like two months in the fiscal year
and we're only halfway to the
recruitment goals and we're going to be
really short so what do you do in that
situation if you're if you can if you
don't have guys
to go send in and get blown up
do you advance your
robots you know robot
autonomous weapons system depends on the
situation gigantic drones and if you
have if if there are robot autonomous
weapons do they fall under 2a does
anyone get to have those
i think they they should they do
like yeah i think it needs to be it
would need to be clarified and codified
but arms means arms so
autonomous robot dogs with uh rifle
shooting eyes it is all a robot dog that
can fire weapon is just it's like an
advanced firing mechanism
the thing about the left and the
anti-gun i shouldn't say the left i hate
doing that the democrats the anti-gun
people is they just don't believe people
have a right to defend themselves and
they don't understand what a fundamental
right is and a fundamental right is like
dude if you if if if a weapon is held by
the government people had the right to
have it so i i'm i'm all on board if
people want to come together and say
like maybe there should be some
limitations because weapons kind of got
crazy in terms of like directed energy
weapons and laser induced plasma
channels now we got drones that can you
can mount stuff on okay maybe we should
have a conversation there i say for the
time being arms or arms whether it's a
flying drone that you put a machine gun
on or a handgun or a bow and arrow or a
knife whatever that's the crazy thing is
that knives aren't covered under arms
what do you mean like you can't have
knives in some place because there's
nothing like you can't remember
knives and stuff like that right yeah
and they say a knife a certain length
and stuff like that certain things are
like well it doesn't count as an arm so
meanwhile there was just a stabbing
attack during a tubing vacation did you
guys see that yeah what was that about
yeah so some crazy guy uh i don't
remember why he was like part of the
trip and he stabbed a 17 year old to
death yeah i sent four other people to
the hospital and they were all just
tubing on a river wow i think it's
typically like interpersonal conflict
that just gets you see the pan now you
see the box box cutter slasher in new
york or whatever no he just like holds
his arm in there and he walks up to a
woman and just slashes her in the back
it's full full force in broad daylight
like could you imagine living on this
subway station no could you imagine
living in new york libby i can imagine
it very well
i live there bro check this out we went
to new york to look to we we did a trip
for all the crew to see the billboards
we put up that morning was when it
happened oh no no i think that yeah i
think the slashing happened that morning
slasher
yeah
just like some some like older woman is
like walking with a little cart and he
just slashes her back so the other day
it was last weekend and i was hanging
out with my son as i tend to do because
he lives in my house and
i was like do you want to go do
something we could go to met i love the
met and also the met is the only museum
in new york that stopped requiring vax
cards so i was like okay i'll go back to
the mat but everybody else the
guggenheim everybody else you have to
show your vax card i think that's still
in effect anyways so i was like you want
to go do this we'll go hang out we'll go
the lego store we'll do fun stuff we'll
walk around and he was like
can't we just drive to jersey and go to
a mall and i was like
yeah we could do that and so instead of
going to manhattan we went to the mall
in new jersey your son is like ready to
be in the suburbs he's just like we're
done here what did he say why i'd rather
do jersey so i said you don't want to
walk around my hat and he was like
it's hot there's probably good stuff at
a mall we can go to a chain restaurant
you can actually we got panza express
we ended up we ended up at a california
pizza kitchen
a classic mall fair it was fun we had a
fun day and we still like did a ton of
walking we just wandered around the mall
a lot yeah i'm
i'm excited for
we we just started construction on the
new facility i'm excited to bring some
some life and energy into west virginia
and uh
i i think these cities
we were trying to expand in new jersey
but they're insane these are insane
communist people yeah new jersey
just they're it's communists it's just
they're walking around waving sickle and
hammer flags and i mean i'm half kidding
but where where we lived there were
stores that were flying like communist
style flags like
i'm not saying literal like soviet flags
they had those they had weird symbol
flags that represented socialist and
communist ideologies and i'm just like
you look man
to a certain degree i'm willing to
engage in my community and expand but
like when it gets to the point when
local people are flying these flags like
maybe it's not safe and we should
go and try and just bring our
investments to other places and you were
on the like philly side of new jersey
right we're on the like we're in south
jersey yeah right on the other side of
philly right and philly is a disaster oh
yeah that's like another reason i was
like time to get out these cities get
well go broke man it it is it is it is
uh what galt's gulch is that what was it
called what's that
in in atlas shrugged
although all the wealthy uh high high
rent like high merit
meritocracy people are just like we're
out we're going to do our own thing and
then everything starts breaking down and
falling apart fine so be it look new
york still got a lot of talented people
running businesses but it's it's a
strain it's getting harder and harder to
do i think cities are awful
so be it i'm looking forward to getting
out and just doing something with less
people i think with new york
i live there for a little bit and part
of it is for most people it's not going
to be a long-term solution and i think
in some ways our culture has shifted so
much with the rise of like work from
home work remote that like you can start
investing in whatever community both
like
financially but also emotionally you can
really set roots earlier because you're
not fighting to establish your career
you can be in a place that's more
reflective of your values i
think that the wave of people that we
saw moving out of cities i mean we
really haven't seen a wave returning
since covid right there's been people
coming back to new york some but not
it's not like they took time off and
then went back i mean people are
discovering that life is sustainable
outside they're going to mexico did you
see that and mexicans are like go home
yeah no so we did a segment about it was
really funny like right in the beginning
lauren southern she's like it's the
great replacement but uh the the segment
we did talking about mexicans getting
angry at americans invading their
country it's got like half a million
views it's getting shared like crazy
it's ironic but i think the reason
people are sharing it is because they're
like yo the sentiment among people when
a large influx of people of a different
culture come in the sentiment that
people feel like negative towards that
it's it's universal
they want to talk about multiculturalism
i was like well it's multicultural to be
upset when your way of life is overnight
disrupted by yeah because you like your
community that's why you're there you're
not there so that it just randomly gets
changed by a bunch of people
who decide they
like it but want it to be in their image
instead of yours i think we should talk
about alex jones now
we got this story from the daily mail
that was a really brilliant segue by
yeah i thought so too oh i just i just
figured it was like it was not a segue
at all it was perfect it's a beautiful
stage january 6 house committee prepares
to subpoena alex jones's emails and
texts for any contact with donald trump
after his legal team mistakenly sent
them to sandy hook parents lawyers
okay i'm just so frustrated i don't know
if you guys were watching the uh the
court case
with um
the alex jones trial no not yet it's
just this is made up stuff
so here's what happens
the the plaintiff's attorney he's like
we've got all of your text messages
because they sent it to us by accident
and alex was like
i gave my cell phone to you i gave
myself into my lawyers to turn over and
they're like you tried to hide it and he
was like
i gave my cell phone to you you have it
and they're like no you gave it to us on
accident and he's like what
this is the craziest thing that they're
saying
definitively that it was mistakenly sent
to them when you have two factions
arguing one side saying it was one side
saying it wasn't why would you just
decide one side is telling the truth
this is the craziest thing to me also
isn't it part of discovery like doesn't
it go to everybody
well so that was the issue they were
arguing that it wasn't sent during
discovery
that it was like not sent during the
typical process or whatever and i'm just
like okay well why would that have been
an accident if they sent them all of his
text messages or something like that
also what is this accent they were just
like i put in the wrong email address i
mean that seems like a strange
coincidence i accidentally gave you this
dropbox link something yeah i
accidentally specifically gave you the
thing that you wanted right yeah i don't
get it and then the judge the judge like
intervened and said
to uh to the jury
to that
we don't know
that it was like he was trying to hide
it or something but we do know they
received it in not in an improper way or
something that sounds like they're
they're doubling
two issues right now they're doubling
the issue of alex and what he said about
sandy hook with this dumb this trump
january 6th thing yeah like what's he on
trial for sandy hook has nothing to do
with the trump has nothing to do with
he's on trial for one reason they're
trying to destroy him his career his
life and everything freaking it's a
clown show they've been going on for
like seven years this is insane he
already admitted what he did was wrong
and that this was actually right and he
said that the media just wouldn't let it
drop but there was one headline today
that was like he admits that no it's
everywhere yeah it's so insane and if
you look at the full quote he's like i
admitted this a long time look at this
look look a long time ago yeah ap alex
jones concedes sandy hook attack was 100
real yo he said that like seven years
ago yeah he conceded it a long time ago
it's not it's not present tense he said
he had used to have so many documents in
front of and he'd read things and then
one night or and he went on this tirade
about sandy hook that he'd got some
information that was bad information he
didn't vet it and it changed his life
ever since
well this is what he told me he said
ever since he's been just
on the evidence he will go deep into
evidence now he doesn't shout stuff out
as much as he used to that fair fair but
i'm not going to cut alex
i'm not going to let him off the hook on
this one there were other people at
infowars that were telling him to stop
and i i had heard this
before the trial started like it was
last year there were people because
we've had alex on the show we've had
other people work with them and they
were like they were telling us people
were telling alex like bro chill on this
stuff you can't do this you can't defame
private citizens like this
apparently it's come out in the trial
they showed emails where staffers at
infowars were were complaining being
like what are you doing even when it
came to the covet stuff people were
getting mad saying like you're you're
saying too much you know
false stuff
so i'll say it outright you you i am i i
think defamation is wrong
alex jones wanted to go on his show and
and and say things that that weren't
true or or you know to to a certain
degree
i think he's got it held accountable
however i think what's going on right
now is anything but that
i mean i feel like the lawyer was super
smarmy it was just like dude i could not
stand listening to the man because he
was like
alex
and i'm like shut up dude just ask a
question like i got to tell you this if
i'm sit i'm if i'm sitting listen to a
lawyer i'm telling you i think alex
jones was wrong in this and i think he
owes the family something then their
lawyer comes out and goes mr jones um
you said this right do you know perjury
is mr jones
and i'm just like wow i really hate this
guy and want alex to win now
cause like he's so awful it's like alex
is up there coughing was he like the
written house prosecutor remember that
guy oh yeah yeah it's just yeah that guy
that guy was annoying except he gave us
the best legal quote of all time don't
get brazen with me
i think
these stories that i heard that you hear
about in the news people show me showing
up to their houses and stuff it's
horrifying
and there were people that worked with
alex that were telling him like back off
and he he went
full steam or i should say he went steam
enough
and then he should have done it now
they're saying they want 150 million
dollars over it and i'm like this is
where it's getting crazy
it doesn't seem like he's getting he's
getting a fair hearing like he didn't
even have he wasn't even granted a jury
trial over this they went straight to uh
uh the damages hearing it's it's it's
totally insane it absolutely is
so
you know look man the most annoying
thing is they're they do these really
dirty games
and what blows my mind is it just works
on on on dumb people
so so one thing they're doing is
alex jo so uh i don't want to use alex
jones a specific example i'll give you a
general example someone will say
something like
do you have i gave the example to ian i
was like ian you have a rock in front of
you this one here is is that rock blue
no
you're testifying right now that there
there is that that is not a blue rock
correct yes okay now hand that rock over
to us
then we'll go ah there it is there is
blue ladies and gentlemen of the jury
the rock
blue right there
did you testify this rock was not blue
mr crossland yes and and clearly we can
see there is blue here do you know what
perjury is mr crossland uh
that's what they're doing that's what
they're doing the annoying thing is like
dude
stupid people will fall for that and
it's really annoying if someone says do
you have x and you go
usually you say something like to the
best of my recollection i don't think so
i don't think i have that now i'm not
saying alex is perfect on this one i'm
not here to defend everything he said or
done i'm saying it's really annoying
when it's like
perjury almost never happens perjury
charges because it's impossible to prove
someone's memory is perfect and they
intended to lie yeah like james clapper
when he said they weren't wittingly
spying on the american citizens
well what's the word wittingly he did
say we weren't wittingly doing it so
they were unwittingly spying as
basically what it came down to so
perjury in this in this instance they
said to alex
uh you testified you didn't have emails
pertaining to sandy hook and he was like
i
i may have been mistaken i don't know i
gave you my phone i gave you my emails
right and then they're just like did you
testify you did not and they want him to
say yes without any kind of nuance or
context
then he says do you know what perjury is
mr jones it's like
to taint the jury into believing that
perjury was committed when he will never
be charged for perjury because the
reality is
he probably just didn't know
it's crazy to me that you know we get
thousands of emails per day across the
board thousands you think i know what's
in there yeah yeah so what they'll do is
they'll say do you have emails and i'll
say i don't know and they'll be like
okay well like you're saying you're
unfamiliar with yes and then they'll
probably be like boom there it is we
have it in your database you had it and
it's like dude i don't read those things
right i mean how many unread email
messages do you have i think mine are in
the
many thousands upon thousands of unread
easily well i just i just mark
everything as red every day just like
really just ignore it i don't do that
well
i just you have a company right so
there's so many email servers that feel
like you don't know what's going on with
your own company tim pool that's crazy
like it's just an impossible standard i
think alex i mean i wonder sometimes
with the way the prosecution is
proceeding as if they're just trying to
get him to feel so irritated he has some
outbursts on the stand that can feed a
media cycle for a little while i mean in
some ways it just seems like they're
trying to get under his skin
they're just trying to destroy
alex jones is a huge arsenal for donald
trump it's a victory and so they're
trying to just go after him in any way
possible to make sure that anybody who's
not
absolutely in politics won't listen to
the man now look
alex is a lot of crazy crazy stuff the
reason we have an alex jones was right
jar is because he says a lot of crazy
stuff so when he's right you put the
money in the jar that's that's the gag
when he went on rogan and talked about
like what is it fourth dimensional fifth
dimensional beings and like 5g cell
towers and animal human hybrids i'm like
okay it's it's it's
all crazy you know what i mean but
there's a lot of things he's talked
about like epstein for instance that
he's been right about and chimeras they
are real i mean yeah that's the thing
it's like he says things in ways often
where you think he's nuts and then you
realize it's true like we him on the
show and he was like we're all eating
cloned beef and i was like what and he's
like yeah we're cloning cows in the neat
and i'm like no we aren't that's crazy
and i pulled it up i'm like oh it's
actually true yeah like we show the
sources saying we we do cloned cloned
beef i thought that they already got
alex in a trial for sandy hook
defamation yeah i thought this wouldn't
we already see this three years ago or
two years ago but it wasn't uh i don't
know the full decision is this civil war
i think this is this is the damages here
yeah oh i see well it's all civil that's
the other thing too the left thinks
there's criminal defamation charges i'm
like we're talking defamation's a civil
civil war i also i don't think anyone
should ever answer yes or no questions
oh i agree it's manipulation every ever
worthwhile i remember getting into a
fight with someone once and they were
yes or no yesterday i was like i told
i'm not even gonna agree with the
premise of your stupid question yeah no
one's you never have to answer a
question with someone else wants you to
no that's ridiculous and you never
should the other thing too is if someone
says like you know ian do you have a
blue rock you say to the best of my
understanding i don't believe so
as opposed to no right
because then they're back you said no
you you said no you it's like well i
said to the best of my understanding i
must have been wrong or why do you want
to know what color my rock is you look
at it yeah i don't know that's why when
the doctor my green could be your blue
when your doctor asks a question
like do you have wasps under your
armpits you say not that i know of
you don't say no because he might be a
magician and have like a wasp up his
sleeve or maybe he's just coming out of
your house he's like well then once he
just didn't know and then there's
another one here it is
doctor says you you're experiencing
wasps under your armpits
anybody who knows that reference will
anyone who understands that reference
will earn a prize no i don't i happen to
have marshall mcluhan right well i'm
proud of your ignorance i'm willing to
bet a bunch of people and some people in
the chat will totally understand that
reference
we'll see though adrian curry i love
libby
ah i love you too adrian thanks that was
nice that's very sweet i wanna you know
what i was thinking with alex jones
this trial is almost meaningless i feel
like alex could just go on the stand
right now and just be like i'm sorry
that it happened
uh i own up to it it shouldn't have
happened i apologize
i hope for forgiveness and i'd love to
try and do what i can and let me know
what you think is is deserving of the
families and we'll do what we can to
help them out did he have the option to
settle out of court well i'm just saying
if he did that
no matter what he does he is still alex
jones and they can never stop this man
yeah like there's literally nothing you
can do worst case scenario they would
bankrupt him make him
close infowars is that what it is they
can't do that that's not possible so
they just bankrupt and then you just
start making money again right so what
so here what they could do is you know
alex said anything over two million
would destroy the company
considering he got de-platformed it's
entirely possible but i almost don't
know if i believe it
because he's syndicated in other places
and there's other ways that infowars
makes money and i really doubt that his
revenue is two million dollars
so
we'll see i also bet alex has been
planning for this
knowing that they were going to come
after him for large sums of money he's
probably shuffled a bit of his wealth
into areas that protect it i hope so
give it to your kids give it to your
kids
give it to uh you know you can't just
give it to them it's taxed
but you can do transfers that shield it
from you know put it into like living
trust yeah trusts are fantastic
yeah it's there's tons of things but i'm
just saying like
even if they were to get the 150 million
what happens tomorrow he goes back in he
does his show
now they might force liquidate his asses
or something but all the man needs is a
cell phone
and they what are they gonna do like
we're taking your phone now from you
it's like you can't phone costs 20 bucks
do you think they just want to be able
to say like he was convicted of
defamation alex jones who was convicted
of defamation and be able to have that
be the sound bite and sort of his
official
moniker for a little while so like again
not that they could necessarily pull it
off but to trash his credibility and try
and purge people who does that i mean i
don't think it would do anything but
maybe they feel like if they can
um
rock the boat on alex jones supporters
they can gain some sort of influence
over a popular narrative and culture
i don't know probably it's a
short-sighted goal but it might be
because i don't other than that they
just want the money but i mean what you
can't get blood out of a stone 150
million if he only has 2 million revenue
like
well i will say
i think alex jones likely has more money
than
he's letting on but i also think
the other side in this is not playing
fair
at all it's the the process is the
punishment kind of thing right they're
just raking them through it
yeah so like one of the things he said
was this is what they do that's how they
get you he said he doesn't do email he
doesn't have email and then they were
like here's a text showing you sending
an email and he was like oh that's like
a personal thing dictated to my
assistant and they're like ah but you
said you didn't have email and it's like
dude oh are you serious yeah like if
someone's if you're like i don't have an
email account but like one time you
might have sent one or two
that's just then they they argue is
perjury and all that stuff and i'm just
like i'm so annoyed by it
because if you if anyone who's sane and
rational looks the nuance outright would
just be like yeah hey screw this one up
you know these families suffered enough
let's sort this one out instead you've
got the opposing lawyer is like one of
the worst people i've ever heard speak
and then everyone's just flinging crap
at each other and i'm like nobody looks
good here well a big part of a big part
of what we have going on now too it's
not just alex jones but it's you know
january 6th committee the department of
justice
the idea is going after not just um
people who worked with trump but anyone
who supported him and we're seeing that
across our justice system i really don't
like this sentiment of i don't like that
guy and i don't like what i was told he
did throw him in prison like the stupid
short legally torture him
well really it is kind of like a
psychological torture it's like uh it's
like the trial did you read that no the
kafka
so
this guy is brought up on charges and
nobody ever tells him what it is that he
did
and it just goes on like that
it's very well it's kafka ask is what it
is what's up with this dude they just
said they destroyed with a drone bomb a
loki no not al-awlaki that's the
this was the monday thing zawari yeah
zawarahari and i'm like didn't they
already kill that guy a decade ago
is this like is this like 1984 where
they're always at war with a country
overseas and it's like every 10 years
they're like we are we have found the
terrorists finally we've killed him like
didn't you get that guy 10 years ago
weird two is a year ago biden said that
al qaeda wasn't in afghanistan
right
now
and now they're saying now there's
another like oh they're
they're still in afghanistan it's like
well why'd you say that a year ago and a
year ago he was gonna call the troops
right yeah and then they got 13 uh 13
service members yeah killed oh so very
badly they retreated and then he well
they they routed and surrendered and now
yeah they said they said that they were
going to work with the taliban to make
sure there was no al-qaeda in
afghanistan excellent exactly
at the time me and literally everybody
else was like oh you're trusting these
guys now you're trusting these guys to
make sure that there aren't terrorists
and they're like they are terrorists
whatever reason like lightning striking
me i i no longer believe or trust when
i'm told in the news that they got a
terrorist leader but with i don't
believe it anymore i don't even know if
the guy was alive to begin with i see no
proof they say that he and his family
were living in kabul i believe that i
think that's like i remember hearing a
description of like it was so they they
he walked onto the balcony and they were
able to take him out right and it didn't
cause any structural harm they didn't
have to hurt anyone in his family
because sometimes they'll just drop a
bomb and like right take everyone i mean
i think they're saying like it was so uh
a show of how clear our how strong our
military is how advanced our technology
is and i i also feel like that's a weird
stance like all of it felt strange yeah
very likely if they blew up a building
or a complex to get this guy that other
people were involved in getting killed
they didn't like that that was the like
and that's what they told us
they said no we just got the one guy
don't worry it's like
i i want this guy on trial i don't want
to i want to stop killing people because
the war on terror is over we ended it 15
years ago or eight years ago how do you
get them on track
i agree with you i don't think we should
you know be
going around committing these kinds of
things but how would you get them on
trial like no one would extradite them
what trial what what court so take a
look at this story from november
november 17th 2020 the death of ayman
al-zawahiri in the future of al-qaeda
daniel l baiman
i suppose the issue was that they
assumed he was dead
and so
later on the news comes out and they're
like okay no now he's actually dead
so that's that's that's what i think
you're gonna think it could be like oh
he's actually alive we didn't get him oh
wait we got him but it's like this just
they said they have no confirmation they
have no dna confirmation okay no
confirmation
yeah maybe next time when he's back that
they'll get him this time and then then
we can
have faith in our government that it's
doing the right thing what just bombing
and killing guys is not the right thing
there's no declared war this is not but
congress is toothless they won't do
anything
so how would they how are they possibly
going to declare war i don't think
anybody's in charge they can't even
agree on like helping veterans you know
i think
everybody's just
screaming at each other and clawing for
power
nobody's really in charge if anyone's in
charge it's xi jinping
he like not that he controls everything
he's being run by somebody too
well i mean to a certain degree he's got
the party and he's trying to maintain
confidence among the people who are
around him but what i mean is
no one there's no control
like there's no there's no single group
just controlling everything they're
trying to yeah and xi jinping probably
has the most power of any individual but
not necessarily the most power of any
group you know what i mean and putin as
well the bankers have a lot of power
like the bank for international students
i don't know what their military
capabilities are though they can have
like private military and they have
access to weapons and stuff but they're
not a nation state the corporations seem
to have a lot of power as well yeah and
they're kind of run by the bankers that
are fluentizing their their capital and
they also just do whatever they're told
by whatever government
uh whatever nation they are you know
invested in
this is the esg stuff you'll look at
nike right nike will do one thing in
china they'll do something else here
look at the way that the whole pride
month thing goes right so like in in
western europe and in the us
you have all of these companies being
like yay pride stuff and then if you
look at their same advertising in saudi
arabia it's like no prizes
for maga month none of our international
accounts changed their pictures to
american flags really that's
disappointing not none of that
i mean what we don't want to offend
other countries
and we don't have an american
but i took the american flag off of my
account because michael month is over
yeah that's what you're supposed to do
you only fly the flag and support during
the one month and then you're done
done my duty now everybody knows i
support america and uh you know back to
work is there a ukraine pride flag that
has like all of it yeah there is there
is a private there is that with ukraine
on it right yeah but is that real
i've never seen it in public i've only
seen on the internet and who knows a lot
of these flags are just graphics is that
what it's turning off
well but like some of them no one
actually made a flag into made into a
flag the crazy thing is like is there a
committee that decides the pride flag
like all of a sudden one day someone's
like this is more inclusive and then
people just start using it well there
was there was a there are people who
invent all of these flags
like if you dig down it's always
somebody invented it we need a
flag
we need to make our own flag gotta get a
flag bearer for people who like for
people who like reading books during
thunderstorms oh that's cute we would
have a lightning bolt on it that would
go over really well and it'll be
gray and blue stripes and we'll we'll
and we'll we'll hold it up like
angrily and like people start throwing
bricks at like
barnes and noble you gotta be careful
with the lightning bolts though why why
is that isn't that like a nazi thing no
but i'm like
it'll be a rainbow storm
alone it'll be with a cloud it'll be
like a my point is like whatever you
identify
oh like a like a care bear it would be
like a care bear yeah like a care bear i
mean i was telling like when people had
family crests right like they had
something to represent it like we just
need a crest we got to bring those back
people feel better
a lot a lion yeah that's an eagle we
were talking about the rothschilds
earlier like who's running the show the
banking industry rothschild is like it
kind of began in the 1500s let it begin
but modern banking with those guys but
rothschild means red shield it was
before they had addresses it was just
all symbols and stuff and they had a red
shield on the front of the house they're
like now they are the red shields so
let's do that again well that's sort of
what we're doing right with red and blue
we have like red states and blue states
but if you go back in history it's
always like that it's like it's always
one group identifies with one color and
the opposing group has a different color
and
that's how they that's how they proceed
and all of the wars and conflicts yeah
that's how we get all that cool tartan
in scotland you're too complicated just
pick a color purple okay i'll be purple
there you go
i want to
pour it off peel it back and then you
see the red underneath or something like
that periwinkle
okay next time we're on the show
everyone better have a craft
if you could fly a flag there's like a
magnifying glass and get it the light
just right so it shines down and shows
you where the gold is that'd be awesome
the thing about a crest though is it's
like we're supposed to hate our
ancestors what if we started identifying
with them you should have ancestor month
now right we're supposed to hate them
because they were all so evil well
terrible i don't know maga month was
july because you know fourth of july
ancestor month could be could be august
who do you think was the best evil
villain from back in the day
which
yeah like if you had to pick one but
like what do you mean by villain like
maybe rasputin it's like killer yeah he
was pretty nasty yeah but i mean like
the world was just crazy yeah well he
was a weird crazy priest up on goofballs
he sure was lots of goofballs
no didn't they try to poison him like a
half dozen times and it didn't take that
might be apocryphal really yeah
like they tried to kill a bunch of
different ways and he wouldn't die well
it's important to hang out to the good
myths but they did uh they did try and
kill the royal family the women and they
are they the bullets were bouncing off
them that's real what yeah because they
had sewed all the gems into their gowns
oh
so i tried to to you know sneak some
wealth out of the palace as they were
getting rounded up and they were they
were shooting with like 22s or something
or what i don't know what they were
shooting the russian royal family with
but i do know that the women had gems
sewn into their gowns and i think a lot
of the guns they had back in the day
were like 22s i could be wrong though
musket balls hard to get through those
are 50 caliber muskets
that'll put a 10 inch hole in your chest
i don't know if the gems are going to
protect you from that
let's uh let's let's talk about this
movie let me see if i can find this one
here we go
this is from the daily mail
holy wolkery batgirl tom leonard
investigates why warner brothers 90
million new superhero movie has been
deemed so awful it will never be
released
so i i saw this and i really wanted to
talk about it because a massive get woke
go broke
apparently they put 90 million dollars
into a batgirl film that was super woke
and they canceled it because when they
showed it to people the people said this
is a terrible movie and you shouldn't
have made it and so they scrapped it
it's a lot of money to scrap i kind of
want to see it now i yeah apparently
that's what's happening people are
saying like give us the film and we'll
finish it let us see but i bet it's
really bad yeah i bet it like
i think we can't hate watch stuff or
even like curiosity watch stuff like
that they'll be like oh so you did buy a
ticket so we should make this like if
they canceled it just let it go like
that's probably good
the audience feedback was so awful that
an almost unprecedented move warner
brothers has decided the reputational
damage of releasing such a dud would be
even worse than wasting the tens of
millions of dollars had already spent on
it
it just didn't work said an insider the
decision is also a blow for glasgow
which has stood in uh
for glasgow which had stood in for
gotham city in the movie okay that's
what you're doing look at this
i don't know but this costume looks like
it's
like
crappy cosplay well they already failed
because we all know that female
superheroes are supposed to wear um mini
skirts and stuff but this is uh this is
but then that's like over sexualizing
her so like can't do that either yeah
they trapped themselves into a corner
where they couldn't market this film
it's not clear who this audience is for
i think this may be the end of what was
in movies i think this shows 90 million
end
they spent a ton of money realized they
made garbage that nobody wanted
i mean how long did it take for people
to finally realize when they're like you
know
maybe your average dude doesn't want to
see a super ripped woman punching people
in the face
maybe and your average woman doesn't
want to see that either exactly
yeah you know i think it was it might
have been uh
bill burr
or i can't remember which comedian it
was they said funny they said that the
wnba should where all the feminists all
the feminists should be out there
watching the wnba but there's nobody
there where the woman at nobody watches
it because nobody cares i want to watch
it
exactly
i don't want to watch men's basketball
what what is this obsession with like
creating men's things for women that
women don't want and men don't want this
is such a weird thing too and especially
in in films and you know narrative
because what they do is they say let's
take this this character that is a male
character and let's just turn it into a
female character and do exactly the same
things with it that we would do with a
male character and then it's like you
know feminist and forward thinking and
progressive and all of that but if
you're going to build a female character
you have to build a female character
that is female at the core you can't
just like
gloss over
you know you can't just like basically
trans a male character in a narrative i
think i know how to do it how to trans
male character how to make batgirl work
for women
here's what you do
it's batgirl right she's a crime
fighting superhero
and then she starts dating batman and he
like is totally into bdsm and he's like
choking her and stuff
you know like because fifty shades of
shades are great i mean women love that
okay but the perfect one was the the
michael keaton batman with
who was it was it michelle pfeiffer was
catwoman that was great it was romantic
it was
it was actiony she was cool
everyone wanted to be catwoman that
halloween but it's catwoman it's not
captain there's no cat man because it's
like that's a female character from we
should make cats yeah but every grade
school kid knows that you know cats are
girls and dogs are boys everyone thinks
it's just the way it is but it is it's
weird everyone thinks cats are girls
okay i'm like i don't understand the
feed blind female it's like we have we
have uh bocas and people are like what's
what's her name and i'm like it's a dude
i mean he's a eunuch right but he's a
dude
and he eunuchs or something
yeah
no but my point was like if you were
going to make a women want different
things right i made this point a couple
days ago i made it several times the
past week when i was on this plane
and we got hit by wind and we fell like
50 feet you just drop
every single one on the plane screams
not a single male did
because like men and women are different
yeah i would i would scream probably
what is the screaming from mostly i
would gasp i don't know but like why did
i scream the the the hypothesis from
evolutionary psychology is that if a
bear if a threat uh
if a woman perceives a threat and she
doesn't scream she's more likely to die
oh so screaming alerts the males of
danger crying the kids the screamers had
the babies the little girls in my
neighborhood when i was a kid would have
screaming contests
oh wow yeah to make sure and it would be
dusk and i would be like at home because
i had to be home by dusk and i would
hear like these screaming and the
neighbors would get so mad everyone
would be like you kids stop screaming we
think something's wrong with you
i think something's wrong oh you think
you need help and they were like it's
just a screaming contest mr laurier
we would have pee in contests we didn't
do that
up on top of the clubhouse that's weird
yeah i'd use i'd win a lot of those
congratulations to the cemetery thanks
into the cemetery yeah we had a cemetery
pissing onto graves never made it to a
grave oh okay too far out
that's horrifying anyway my point was i
saw this story i want to talk about it
because i'm thinking like it's been it's
been over a decade since the rise of
wokeness
and now we see like critical race theory
critical gender theory but this is huge
because if they're willing to tank 90
million dollars without and they don't
want anyone to see this you know maybe
they're starting to realize it
this stuff doesn't work the old stories
are not bad stories the old narratives
are there for a reason they've lasted
thousands of years for reasons it's
because we relate to them we understand
them it's because they're part of the
the narrative that we use to tell
ourselves the story of humanity and the
story of our lives did you guys catch
tomb raider or ever follow that game or
movie uh yeah it was uh what's her name
played
yeah
is there like any desire or interest in
like a woman with a sword that's a
badass fighter
hold on hold on but you don't get it i
recently watched tomb raider because it
was recommended on amazon and it's
clearly just a movie for for dudes dude
like angelino jolie's boobs are like
mushed forward and pointy like the tomb
raider character because they only had
polygons or whatever they had very few
polygons and there's actually like a
scene of her just naked in the shower
for no reason yeah it's like the movie
was clearly not for girls to be like
yeah like i'm going to be strong like
her and i was like dude's watching a big
breasted woman there are like there are
fun movies that are like actiony
rom-commy type movies like i was
thinking about this the other day
remember the dead sean of the dead was
great romantic comedy with zombies
i love that movie see boom there it is
make more i've been told i have bad
taste in movies i love that movie i'm
always fantastic it's great
uh
but um what was i saying before i got
sidetracked by that movie oh you
remember the uh remember heather used to
be all those old movies with uh michael
douglas and kathleen turner
do you guys know okay are you talking
about okay what's an example what's one
of them ant-man
they did a movie called romancing the
stone which was kind of like it was kind
of like indiana jones but they were
teamed up at the beginning and they
hated each other and then they fall in
love and everybody gets soaking wet in
the waterfall and there's diamonds and
things and then they go off on some
paradise because they're rich now you
know what women fantasize about this is
this is like what these movies were and
they did very well
i was thinking now they're like let's
just have a woman be like a super ripped
muscular boxer yeah who hates men yeah
and has absolutely and you can't tell at
all what her priorities are or what she
wants in life
like what do these characters want and
the men are one dimensional and they're
like you can't be a boxer you're a woman
according to romance in the stone they
want overcoming miscommunication so like
they didn't like each other then they
realized oh we actually do like
they want adventure yeah um and to be
rich
and then to retire and comfort and to
look good doesn't mean you look fine
while you're doing it yeah there was a
there was like kathleen turner there was
a meme in the 80s that might not be true
but someone posted on the internet and
went viral they said the male power
fantasy is to save
everyone the children the women other
men to put the fire out to be a
superhero that's why guys love these
movies war movies it's to like save
everyone and the female power fantasy is
to be able to do whatever you want
without consequences so in like a lot of
romantic comedies it's about the
bumbling you know woman who just gets
what she wants in the end you know
through his adventure or something i'd
argue the woman in uh i don't remember
her name but gone girl like that female
character is crazy to me i would watch
her all day long because she gets to do
whatever she wants because she's
operating on a really intense
psychological level i think women
i i have never really been interested in
watching girls fight like physical
combat with women if you're if that's
what you want to watch fine but i don't
think it has the same appeal for a
female character as seeing female
characters
control a situation psychologically or
through emotion i think that's much more
of a feminine trait than seeing them
punch someone and that's why when you
see really real well-written characters
they are in some ways reflective of true
gender norms
i think that's really interesting you're
making me i keep thinking about game of
thrones i don't you probably guys
probably have seen it if not but there's
this character called uh brienne of
tarth there was this woman who that was
like a warrior and she was huge she's
like six five or something and she's
pretty big for a woman but they put her
in this armor and she could barely move
in the armor it was like
grating and embarrassing to watch and if
society didn't want to talk about how
how horribly awkward it was to put this
woman in this massive heavy armor she
could barely move but they were just
like trying to shove it down my throat
like this is what a woman wore you're
like dude at least like put her in
something she can she can
carry
like so it doesn't look embarrassing
like oh it's just
disgusting to watch it was really really
piss-poor
that they did that i'm sorry you had to
watch that yeah it was it was like and i
you know i didn't even realize how bad
it was until halfway through this
i just can't lie to myself anymore the
casting of brie larson is is captain
marvel for those that are familiar just
made literally no sense to me because
she's like a short frail woman who's
supposed to be this like great warrior
this massively super powerful being and
i'm just like pick your narrative man
like what are you going for
you're going for a short very thin frail
woman they might as well have cast
kristen chenoweth instead i don't know
man well i think all this stuff is going
to start backfiring on them well because
no one will look at look at look at the
uh look at
what was that top top gun
like that did great right it was fairly
generic they didn't even mention the
name of the enemy country but i think
this is the same thing in the first half
but anyway and it was good it was just
like a regular movie i thought what you
said was very insightful that women uh
their power fantasy is manipulating
people as opposed to the man is fighting
people because like i've been listening
to a lot of psychologists i think jordan
peterson and other people have been
talking about women like high school
girls will their power thing is they
will manipulate others and make other
girls feel bad about themselves oh yeah
whereas the guys will bully they'll like
push it's much more efficient i mean you
hear people say like with men and women
like women are grudge holders right and
like the idea it's kind of a stereotype
but like guys if the if the argument
gets really heated eventually they'll
just throw punches and then it's kind of
over right they have a way to physically
de-escalate a situation where if with
women we don't i mean some girls do i
guess but like for the most part they
aren't as prone to physical violence
they are much more prone to like social
and emotional manipulation because they
are in some ways more in tune to that
naturally and so like i just have never
really understood these
like why the push to have women be
physical fighters when they actually are
crazy in another realm like they can be
maybe that's why
ocean's eight make a bunch of money the
all-female reboot of ocean's eleven like
actually it did really well oh i don't
know yet yeah i think it actually made a
lot of money well john
john mullaney had this joke about
before it came out like you could never
have an all-female cast of whatever
ocean's movie because
women you know there would be seven of
them and then two would split off to
talk you know talk about the rest of
them like it doesn't trash it doesn't
work it's not reflective i mean with uh
thor love and thunder
we talk like
natalie portman got a lot of heat for
like uh her arms actually it's right by
the cgi whatever but what is that
i think to a certain extent yeah i mean
she's petite like even in i from i'm not
an expert please don't judge me on this
but like from the comic books it's
actually like a six foot tall kind of
like
much more athletic looking i imagine
like a volleyball player body type uh
and they chose that i mean maybe natalie
portman is perfect for a lot of other
reasons i can't they cast her in the
role
right but they were like it's better to
have this very petite woman
and then it kind of defies expectations
because she's actually a great warrior
or something like i don't understand why
this is appealing at all i don't i don't
think it's that there's there's another
there's another like i think woman's
power fantasy too that i think uh
is very taboo to talk about these days
but that we can hear in you know old pop
music for example like if you look at
amy winehouse on holy war right so the
fantasy in that song is that she's gonna
back her man no matter what if you look
at like
a song that i recently remembered and
started listening to i was like oh this
is great uh midnight train to georgia
right gladys knight
she's singing about how this man she's
in love with is leaving la because his
dreams didn't turn out right and he's
going back to georgia and she's like i'm
totally going with him you know i would
never know songwriting is so much better
you know
but amy winehouse and you know gladys
knight and there's others you know like
you hear it i think in some aretha songs
as well um but this idea that the
the fantasy isn't about
uh your own aggrandizement or your own
you know success or power manipulation
but you know your greatness lies in
boosting your man you know and like the
whole power behind the throne thing yeah
i mean i think i say manipulation but
like really women if you think of like
the stereotype of like hunter-gatherer
right like the men go out and they have
to like be physical they have to hunt
and capture things but women stay home
and basically hang out with the other
women and the kids and they have to keep
an eye on what's going on like there is
a different skill set that's needed to
do that i don't i mean maybe they would
fight in the village but for the most
part you really have to learn how to
navigate socially that's why
just take a look at the noble
domesticated fowl
oh yes the chicken the chicken and the
rooster
and now the rooster will run into danger
sacrificing himself to protect the hens
when you watch the chickens eating all
the ladies are like pecking the ground
and the rooster's standing upright just
looking around he's like nobody coming
near my ladies
and then they're sweet if a fox will
come it does seem that way well
and then he takes what he wants sure you
know what i'm saying and then the
chickens just you know they're like oh
right here you can hear them yeah do you
think they think like here he comes when
he comes walking in the room sometimes
they run
and it's like really really crazy to
watch like the chickens are like just
frantic and the bruiser's chasing them
but no like if a fox shows up the
rooster will run straight at it knowing
it will die
giving the hens time to flee have you
seen this has this has this happened on
chicken city we had a hawk attack no way
and the rooster ran towards the gate and
then stood in front of it making noises
as the hens all ran in and then he went
in last wow yeah it was crazy to watch
he was like not gonna go in until all
the girls were inside that's cool but
like the hens are really dumb
so i think what he was doing was he went
to the door it was a small little door
to show them where it was they so
they'll follow him and then he waits
outside for them to get safe and then
the hawk i think the hawk actually got
hit one of our chickens and then
wasn't able to get off with it and then
the you know the rooster roberto but
roberto's been retired he was just he
was banging his daughters too much you
know yeah he can't stop he can't let
that go well in chicken society it's
called line breeding it's kind of okay
but when he has too many kids then it's
like okay buddy like
you're you're off yeah but no thanks we
uh you were right about ocean's eight
the uh the sequel all women's sequel it
budgeted 70 million to make and they
made 300 million worldwide because it
was about a bunch of women who were
manipulative and catty and stole a bunch
of money from dudes
it made slightly less than ocean's 13
but it also cost slightly less to make
so see there you go seem like they're
just doing so so you want to do a movie
about women make them sly and
manipulative
people are going to be all down for it
oh and tell women stories as opposed to
like just grafting women on top of men's
stories yeah i like the idea of
supporting the man only because the man
then supports the children yeah i mean
this is an old story right this is like
an old classic narrative like the
there's the bible story who is it is it
i'm gonna get the name wrong is it
esther it's one of them right and she
ends up married to
the king or whatever and he's not jewish
and she's not his biggest fan but like
he she ends up bringing him around and
then he does right by the
by the israelites and it all works out
we should we should make a movie where
it's like the main characters are the
women who are married to the superheroes
and then like all the superhero stuff is
just ancillary background stuff like mob
wives is that what it is i don't know
but it seems like that would be what
that would be and i was gonna say but
it's just like the women doing things
that support the infrastructure behind
the superhero and so it's more of like
an interpersonal drama yeah the show
should be called superheroes but it's
about the women no this is a great idea
and it shouldn't be called that but i
like this
but i like this idea this would be a
really fun film this would be a really
fun film to write and to watch and to
costume i mean this would be great
costumes it was like actually writ
written as like a story women were
interested in hearing as opposed to just
like making the women big burly
superheroes punching guys right no i
mean this is not a movie that hollywood
would produce right now because we
aren't supposed to have women who are
like
secondary or playing wives and mother
figures right like that's not supposed
to be but it would be great
but that's the story that most women are
starting at like
a day party you know and like all the
moms are coming over and there's like a
pool party and all the kids have like
weird things they can do because their
dads are superheroes and they're all
just today
but then you gotta have a villain like
slams down from the sky and attacks the
party that's if you want to get everyone
to like it no the the villain would be
the wife i feel like it's always
happening in the background dylan would
be like yeah that would be the wife of
the super villain and she would come in
and you would think she's the villain
and then it would turn out that she's
actually really nice and no no way she
invites everyone to like the
i don't know it turns out
it turns out the villain is the super
villain's wife
and the superheroes wife and the
villains were fighting because they were
at a department store and there was one
cute dress on sale and the villain's
wife bought it first okay that's nice
and now they just
you know
you guys are out of the writer's room
you're just throwing the villain
trying to write for women it's like you
are off this that's not what it would be
no but it would be like this but if you
want to go really classic it would
obviously there would be some sort of a
fair situation
an affair yeah so like the villain the
super villain's wife is actually like
having an affair with like the oh that's
actually the chad superhero yeah
the chad superhero's wife is actually
like she's the leader you know because
there's always a leader there's always
there's always a head of the girl back
so she's in charge and then it turns out
and blah blah blah yeah actually it's
much more interpersonal like i get what
you're saying like it might be nice to
have someone explode but yeah and like
the the the superhero the top
superhero's wife's best friend would
start to know about the affair yeah she
doesn't know if she should tell
there's ethical conflict we're not
complicated guys
like um nature colors like almost a
little overexposed and it's like a weird
suburb of some kind yes yes
yeah so i hope
about it they get secluded in a room or
just got to confront her what happens
when the pop when when the public hears
that
you know he's intimate with
you know the family
one time it happened one time nobody's
gone
one time and then you have like these
great scenes like at a like at a
run-down roadside motel
you know and you have like the loud
sound of like real cicadas and
uh the weird guy who's like smoking
cigars and it's sort of like the light
is weird and then you cut to a scene of
like their kids playing together but you
got about it you got to do something you
got to do it suicide no you got it you
got no suicide but like the villains
stop you don't get anything okay yeah
i'll just give you you got to do a scene
the wife of the chad superhero like goes
to confront him and she finds him at
this old motel and it's like
thunderstorming and then she's like
catches him in the room and then she
screams and she storms out and then he
runs out after and they're both in the
rain and he's like don't do this and
she's like you did to me and they're
arguing and this rain pouring down and
then he picks her up and they kiss in
the rain right and then we have a and
then we have a you know stand by my man
moment like she stand and the only way
that she can stand by the man is they
got to get rid of the villain wife and
now they're like super billions um but
that's ultimately feeding the conflict
between the super villain and the hero
yeah and then they leave town and then
you have a sequel because now the
villain and the villain's wife had to
start over somewhere else no no no turns
out they're villains they're into it
they're swingers yeah but they still
have to leave they can't go to the pool
parties anymore oh yeah you can't and
like then you have the kids being like
why can't we play with evil junior i
don't understand we'll work on the name
and and the you know the thing and you
have this moment when you say like what
do i say she only wears versace yes yes
she's a wrap dress girl all right let's
go to super chats if you haven't already
my friends would you kindly smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends head
over to timcast.com we've got some
stories for you in the uncensored after
show which we'll go up about 11 p.m over
at timcast.com so sign up if you want to
watch that and uh follow follow the show
at tim castrol yadda yadda let's uh
let's read some super chats
all right
let's see
matthew recamp says with convention of
states looming some people have been
talking about a deficit tax on congress
as an alternative to a balanced budget
amendment so that congress would have an
incentive to not overspend what are your
thoughts i don't know what you mean by a
deficit tax you mean like tax their
wages or something do you guys know what
that is sounds like that's what it would
be
because if unless you're gonna go at
their personal bank accounts you would
just be taking it from the taxpayer then
it's just a bunch of rich people being
like i don't care about my salary
take whatever you want oh negative
whatever
yep
bear says found a wiki that records all
the politicians ties socialist communist
groups aoc and photo with north korean
activists check out
uh keywiki.org is that what it is i
don't know
i feel like i'm getting a virus if i
type that in yeah but maybe it's really
useful i don't know what was it
wiki.org
crackerjack says tim i'm now a proud
member of timcast.com have you guys ever
tried nordic bread it could be a good
alternative to bread love you all i
haven't but i've had skier before have
you guys ever had that no when i went to
iceland it's like it's like their
version of yogurt i guess it's different
yeah it's really good you can there are
some grocery stores that sell it in
america but
all right
let's see let's grab some more super
chutes
raymond g stanley jr says i can't vote
democrat in pa primary wtf other states
yeah seriously open primaries are messed
up
monkey ninja
says i'm from kansas and usually
extremely conservative but voted no i
can't argue for the right to defend my
property against intruders and vote
against women's rights to do the same
with their own bodies
i don't i don't i don't know if that's
the case though i mean the issue was the
state supreme court ruled that the
constitution defends the right to
abortion and there would be an amendment
saying the constitution does not there
would still be an issue of legislation
in terms of abortion restrictions west
virginia has a constitutional
amendment that says there's no
protection for abortion but they do
allow abortion in certain exceptions i
mean like i think the fear behind a lot
of what happened in kansas was the push
that it was like it's opening the door
to a complete and total ban and like the
panic that ensued i could understand if
people said you know i
oppose abortion for myself i wouldn't do
it for myself but i don't feel like i
can keep other people from it and that's
why you voted now but i don't know
there's a i mean a lot of people in
europe think we're absolutely insane for
having areas in the country where you
can have abortions through
you know the end of the pregnancy
which is crazy i mean and i think in
sweden it's like 18 weeks yeah you know
and they're like oh we're so civilized
in the us you can't have abortions and
it's like actually
here we can kind of do whatever it just
depends on where you are you know
um so it's very interesting it is one of
the side effects of federalism really
yeah
true halo says az is not an open primary
state unless you are registered as
independent where you can choose which
party in the primary oh that's
interesting so maybe they registered as
independents it would have been 100 000
in independents who were i really doubt
that's the case i feel like that's
really doubt
um traditionally mason m points out as
an arizona it's hard to vote for kerry
lake with her past supporting obama or
the child drag show rumors she's also
very flimsy on public education which is
a big issue in arizona i love the show i
heard i've heard a lot of people talking
about the the past voting for obama
stuff a lot of people i voted for obama
yeah i did two in 2008
yeah 2008 and then 2012 i was like well
that was dumb and then i was just pissed
off and then when 2016 came around i was
like get out of here i don't care who
you are see if she supported the posts
drone bomb psycho obama psych obama or
if it was 2008 hope and change no no
look he had a lot of us nine million
people opted nine million people who
voted for obama in 2012 voted for trump
in 2016. trump was a moderate and a lot
of people were waking up to reality i
don't think it's fair to see somebody
who was like hey you know what i
realized y'all were right about this and
then be like don't care you are forever
tainted by being wrong before like no
that's supposed to be the opposite of
cancer culture so if somebody you know
voted for obama i did and then i was
like well that was dumb like you'd be
like thank you thank you for for
figuring it out and being correct you
know what i mean
all right
cromulus says i sometimes despair being
born in this time my generation will
inherit a broken system we will fight
world war iii while our history and
culture is erased the time is now to be
a strong man do not go gentle into that
good night um i disagree you are you
know may you live in interesting times
i think
no matter when you're born something's
happening imagine being a boomer and
being drafted into vietnam
you know i guess gen xers are like a
lost generation right everyone forgets
they exist we're a very small generation
and the reason for that uh there's a
couple of reasons one is the vietnam war
so a lot of our
would-be parents ended up being killed
would be fathers rather
uh another reason is abortion was
legalized 73 right in this role and then
also contraception uh the pill came in
about the same time so
there are a lot less gen xers now on the
plus side we all got into college
it was it was nice plus yeah i don't
know did you like that was that good for
you uh yeah because i would have had a
real doozy of a time getting into
college otherwise i believe i
yeah yeah i was accepted to to pretty
much one school that i applied to oh wow
and so i went to it nice um yeah
limiting the decisions my mom made me go
um i didn't want to go to college at all
but anyway here's a here's an
interesting one mark eckstein says i'm
an arizona voter i had declare party and
was only able to vote in that party's
primary i will admit i voted for robson
because i preferred her policies but
when it comes for uh comes for the the
general i am going to vote for the gop
interesting
i i think you know
i i think carrie lake's great
i don't know
i'm not arizonan so i don't know exactly
what arizonans need or why that's why
i'm kind of like well i don't want to
say too much i don't want
you know to tell people in arizona how
to live their lives she's always been a
really gracious guest when she's been
here she's always she's ready yeah
personally i like her a lot but it's
just kind of almost irrelevant to
politics so i don't talk about it much i
wanna i wanna come in and bring uh you
know fight
fight in west virginia for uh
you know liberty individualism i don't
like that a lot of these schools what's
happening so i'll put it this way i
really don't like the idea of being this
like city slicker moving into west
virginia and being like nah i'm going to
start voting on these policies and
funding them that sounds terrible but
then what i keep hearing from people is
they need help because
michigan i'm sorry not michigan
virginians and marylanders are coming in
and bringing critical race theory into
west virginia because they're fleeing
the states they destroyed with their
garbage policies going into west
virginia and then voting for those same
policies and so they're like we need we
need help
you know and i'm like well you know
we'll see what we can do we've got some
plans buy billboards all over the state
saying shelly moore sold you out
with that gun control garbage
all right
what do we got here lethal 5670 says i'm
still trying to find the full bill to
read but measure 114 in oregon sounds
like it will make us have stricter gun
laws than california if it does pass
sounds like i'll be homeless in west
virginia
constitutional care in west virginia
and a lot of people are homeless in west
virginia live in trailers it's crazy
when you go out to the middle of west
virginia it's the coolest thing ever i
really really love the middle of nowhere
it's kind of like where i grew up
northeast ohio as soon as you start to
go like an hour west it's just farm town
corn i mean there's a relationship no no
you you don't understand i'm talking
about in the middle of nowhere there's
no corn it's just like rocks and trees
and then you're driving down these
single lane dirt roads
houses and it's just like well water
limited power and electricity generators
like some of them don't even have only
on the grid they have like just big
diesel generators or something it's
crazy to see and there's a lot of people
who live in little trailers
it's really cool when we drove through
the mountains
uh in central west virginia and then you
just come come across an rv at the top
of the mountain and i'm like how did
they get that thing there dude we were
at the gas station traveling across the
country this weekend and like i i just
get this i see all these people like
pulling up all peacefully getting their
gas i'm like what if we had no gas this
whole
the whole society would be a problem
yeah if that gets
it's way too vulnerable
all right honk goes the dynamite says
rush limbaugh encouraged voting in other
primaries in 2008. it was called
operation chaos
yeah
not the biggest fan i think it's
breaking the system up but you know well
it is chaotic
i'm not the arbiter of morality here you
know
it's funny though intelligible noise
says here's my solution to strategic
crossover voting roll over all primary
votes to the election day totals of the
winner of said primary this would
nullify tampering and make dems vote for
the gop
oh by making demons of course if you
vote for someone in the primary and they
win then your votes automatically set
for the general that makes a lot of
sense that's a good idea
yeah
yeah so if you vote for carrie lake in
the primary you don't got to do anything
you already voted for
and then everyone else who didn't vote
for it gets to say it would make it way
easier to count the votes for the
general because a lot of them are
already done
all right raymond g stanley jr says this
is this is the this is way we dig irl
comedy over world war three
what were we we're we're having a laugh
about something what we're laughing
about
all right clint torres says tim i think
i remember you mentioned something about
having theological discussions last week
might i recommend a discussion with
father mike schmitz i love his bible in
a in a here podcast
his bible in a year or if i want to hear
he's the most trustworthy theologian
i've ever experienced i think someone
recommended we we do like a special or
something with him i got a theological
question for you libby
jesus or moses
would he
what if you had to pick one well you
can't pick one so you're good at
answering questions and the way you want
to answer them yeah that's correct but
what does that mean jesus or what would
you pick jesus or moses i don't know the
question who do you like better i don't
know i don't you don't have a preference
who do you like moses
daddy moses dude because he was like the
first he like
god spoke he was all tripping on the i
was like acacia book and he like he was
a slave and then he found out he was
like raised by royalty and then realized
he was like actually a jew and when he
was like have this ethical con you know
like and he went out fighting for the
slaves yeah yeah moses i watched that
movie with christian bale i haven't seen
it
he screwed up you know he totally he
smashed the he smashed the tablets
his bro
is one of them
he smashed uh he smashed that coming
down off mount sinai when he found out
that the israelites were worshiping
false gods oh yeah because the
israelites are all they always go around
and screw up every time so i was during
the pandemic my son and i were reading
the old testament and um you know over
and over again it would be like and the
israelites turned away from god and my
son was finally like that never works
out well for the israelites and i was
like no it doesn't let's just keep that
in mind it doesn't work out well
let's read some more we got donald devol
he says 1984 mondale versus reagan
reagan wins 524 versus 10 electoral
votes winning 58.8 of the popular vote
if it was 2020 walter mondale narrowly
wins by receiving more votes than any
other president in history
i thank the um i think people need to
understand
about a 50 or 49 state landslide is that
you don't need 80 of the vote to do it
you can you can win every state with 51
percent it's just you just need to win
in those states people don't get it
so when we saw these big these
landslides nixon and reagan
it wasn't it was like you know 58
which is big relative to what we've seen
all right let's see
what is this
really now says one more support for tim
cast to officially asking libby out for
a drink
oh that's really cute
yes i just i want to say now that i'm
like i get to say something uh there is
no jesus without moses
that's probably true so that i mean
moses dude
you need them all you need them you need
people willing to break slaves free and
flee across the world with them well
give them a place to live
here we go oh hell no jesus broke us
from the chain of our sins the entire
alex jones hearing is being recorded by
cameras off to the side for a future
made for tv documentary the judge and
prosecuting attorneys are even acting
more dramatic just for that that
explains it this is what i mean like i
think they are trying to irritate him
into having some big alex jones type
ranty outburst that they can then use
for something this is why he shouldn't
have given them this
does he think that they're gonna be like
oh now we've decided that alex jones is
right he should have been like no we're
done
like no no movie for you no made for tv
anything why give them that i don't
understand
i don't know what you mean give him that
like he acquiesced to doing this that he
could he have just settled out
i mean my understanding is that he
offered some extremely low number like
ten thousand dollars something but i
don't trust the corporate press
reporting on this to be completely
honest so
i don't know man
i
i can tell you this
what i do know is that people who are
you know associated with infowars told
me things like
people who worked there said alex you
got to stop saying this stuff before the
trial happened then the trial happened
and they show emails of exactly what was
said so people who who left infowars
have been saying this
is what it is
man dorian holm says hey tim have you
guys seen the fbi's domestic terrorism
symbol [ __ ] that got leaked recommend
looking into it we did the gadsden flag
yeah the i think the black and gold flag
the revolutionary war symbols yup from
the american revolution
freed us from tyranny i mean come on
like that is not that's insane
waffle sensei the empirical says i've
always held that alex is on the autism
spectrum and don't mean it disparagingly
i mean he has a superhuman memory and
that he can remember a news article from
15 years ago but struggles translating
it to people
i got to be honest man i'm not trying to
be mean here but i think
there's a drinking problem there i think
he said that he said that explicitly
that his biggest problem was when he
would drink and then do a show because
he would just say the dumbest stuff he
would be he'd confuse stuff he'd forget
stuff
and so
yep
yep
dan says sending my first super chat for
libby i'm trying to meet someone just
like her someday hopefully soon before
the world ends and then a bunch of heart
emojis please send all of your uh
resumes bank statements and head shots
to tim he'll be screening all of libby's
suitors oh not me no we have staff for
that though
all right it'll be in your email just be
marked red
logan leroy says tim i'm a med student
at the university of uh ks i voted yes
on the initiative that failed yesterday
some of my pro-abortion classmates
brought in champagne to celebrate today
even if you support pro-choice you
shouldn't be celebrating abortion to
that extent that's how i feel but the
modern left is pro-abortion just
outright pro-abortion so on the other
hand they're not but they are drink some
champagne
yeah i guess i mean once there's
champagne it's already opened
yeah get it before the bubbles are gonna
die yeah you just gotta drink it greedo
says the missile had blades on it no
explosives yeah wasn't it called like a
ninja missile or something what missile
a shredder the missile they fired to
kill al zawahiri it like they fire it
and then it spins and fires blades and
they just
shred you to pieces that sounds like a
weird star wars thing
oh doesn't star wars use energy weapons
like lightsabers they do both yeah but
then they do other stuff too yeah they
have vibro blades which are fibroblades
yeah they just vibrate so fast that they
cut through bone like butter but they're
not energy weapons ah
also i heard in the extended lore they
had um
there were i think the storm troopers
they fired slugs because the lightsabers
couldn't deflect them oh okay yeah
ballistics are gonna do well in space
energy weapons are great but ballistics
will go right through a hall of the ship
if they don't have uh armor
um yeah i mean they'll have shields that
block the lasers but then the the
bullets will go through the shields that
hit the wall so you're gonna need hull
armor and shields what what what sci-fi
series did that i was watching it and
they used they used bullets and
spaceships
i can't remember which one though
recently
it was a recent one or you watched it
recently but it was old uh maybe it was
old maybe it's something like an old
concept no no it's a new almost all
space stuff was always like pew pew
lasers and photon torpedoes this was
like they were shooting guns and i was
like they have no shields it's just
ripping through the hole
you know crazy interesting yeah
guns in space
all right
jared gutierrez says pelosi went to
celebrate giving access to over two
billion dollars in education to prc
confucius schools why shoot down a
person who just gave you money
people are saying battle star was it the
expanse
halo firefly
what a great theme it was a great show
it was really a lot of fun to watch they
made rimworld the video games basically
based on fire yeah it's a great game
and then serenity was the name of the
ship it didn't do well the sh the movie
yeah who cares i watched it anyway but
yeah it was the ship
yeah that was great malcolm mcdowell is
that i would have watched a whole bunch
more of that i think a lot of people
would
stacy strickland says previous
conversation that mentioned restaurants
in new jersey is it still hard to order
sweet tea in northern states random but
you used to get looked at sideways and
wondering it's normalizing up there
i'm i don't know i don't know anybody
orders luke orders half sweet tea i
didn't know
when you would get iced tea when i grew
up in the northeast and i grew up in new
england
if you would have to ask for sugar to
add it it's not like when they make the
simple syrup and add it and it's always
like that but i think the spread of some
chain restaurants like i think
chick-fil-a always has a sweetened iced
tea and i think that is sort of making
it seem more normal and i think
some of the like uh
big brand name drinks also produce uh
sweet iced tea so
i always drink unsweetened iced tea and
i'll ask at restaurants you have iced
tea and they'll say well it's
unsweetened sort of apologetically and
i'm like good like why would you i don't
want sugar why would you put sugar in
your iced tea i didn't even i didn't
have i see for years because my family
like makes tea every morning i write a
story about a guy who drank nothing but
iced tea and then he died what from what
really he was like heart attacks yeah
i'm kidding
he doesn't know there was actual story
about a guy who was uh uh he drank
nothing but unsweet tea and he died in
like his forties and that they i think
it was related that's what the story was
like he didn't drink water he didn't
drink water well that's i mean
rehydration
right away he was getting some kind of
build-up or something i did have iced
tea over the weekend it was gorgeous it
was good all right let's read some more
we got thomas williams says i agree
going after alex jones for false
information about sandy hook
i also want the same standards for all
major networks msnbc cnn so on your
false opinions have consequences your
false opinions are uh protected in this
instance it was that alex jones said
definitive things
now i i think what they're arguing is
and again i i don't know every detail of
the case
he he was saying that he was like
reading things from his audience and
stuff like that
and then asking questions and i think
they determined look the standard for
private citizens is way way lower than
republic figures
maybe he could have argued involuntary
public figures like they did with the
covington catholic kids and apparently
getting away with it because those cases
are getting dismissed but you know
i'm hearing that it was battle star in
the the recent battle star
recent battle star the recent one what's
which
yeah that had um cara well that's not
real 20 years ago or something yeah but
15 years ago it's the remake though but
that they had the bullets
yeah there was something else i was
watching recently though at bullets in
space
i don't know maybe it was like a low
budget movie i can't remember i watch
random stuff on amazon
stefan bucksev says regarding alex jones
talk to barnes he explains really well
how he's getting railroaded technically
the judge has already broken texas law
regarding how he has tried too long of
an explanation for a super chat
interesting
so appeal on the hurricane he's in texas
this case is in texas yeah oh wow
the people were sitting in connecticut
or something
i think the previous case was i remember
uh
he didn't show up to it in person which
is okay and there's some back and forth
but there's there were two separate
legal motions and this one is in texas
people are saying it's the expanse
i don't know they could be wrong but a
lot of people just
yeah that means maybe both
common sci-fi theme
trox says usa will not let taiwan fall
taiwan invasion equals world war iv we
have already had a cold world war three
we have been putting this war off
denying taiwan independence i don't
agree with that i think that it's just
one of these colonization tactics and
it's been planned for a long time that
china it's part of i mean it's right
next to china china's taking taiwan yeah
they they definitely are and there's
nothing we can do about it yeah they're
moving industry to the states yeah like
the last few months they have been
they're just preparing for the
transition we just don't have the
leadership to do anything
donald trump said he would nuke beijing
if they tried yeah and he was the crazy
person with the knife and he was like
maybe they believed me five percent but
it's enough that's yeah that was i don't
know man it's kind of scary because i
think it was enough even the left they
were like donald trump could start a
nuclear war and i'm like
yeah he wants you to think that he might
he just might
it's like but that like doubt was really
to his strength right like even if it's
only five percent well you were saying
if there's a crazy guy like if you're if
you're if you're building on your block
is on the corner and there's a crazy
looking guy twirling a gun around and
he's like shaking it and pointing it
around you'd be like from that guy yeah
you're the one house not getting robbed
cause like a crazy guy you can't argue
with you know if they saw somebody
they'd be like i bet i can take him but
a crazy guy was just like shaking his
gun you're gonna be like damn i'm not
going anywhere near that guy that's
right i actually saw a guy in my
neighborhood the other day and he uh
he had what looked to be like a little
machine gun type of thing and he was
like pointing it around and stuff and it
took a while before i saw that it had
like a orange tip
and i was i was like i this is totally
freaked out i've heard kids get shot or
one guy in particular i think was in
ohio got shot for that a cop saw him and
thought he had a real gun so he killed
him yeah that that's happened oh that's
not my kid's not allowed to take his
nerf down to the park not in this era
no way
all right
diesel addict ryan says chicken ian the
hero we didn't didn't know we needed
until we saw him long live chicken ian
yes
people were i saw i saw uh like
libertarian people sharing the cartoon
so for those familiar at chicken city
youtube channel there's a cartoon we
asked an ai i typed in like the
parameters like ian feder reserve
chickens and they wrote this very like
it wrote this story it was like one day
ian went to school and he was bullied by
you know a rooster and so then we turned
it into a cartoon
and then ian goes on this rant about the
federal reserve and then the chickens so
i think take over the federal reserve it
was shut down i think that the ai wrote
the story and then kent wrote the
dialogue was that right
i wrote the premise it was like kent
shout out to that ian the chicken goes
to school and was bullied and then you
know
and then yeah all the dialogue was
written by ken
your graphene book bag yeah that's great
i wanted to make it into a into a show
because that was really hilarious yeah i
want to rename the character from
chickening into some like wilbert or
something rooster ian rooster yeah right
yeah um big news though we're filming
our music video we filmed half of it for
the song that we're putting out in a
couple of weeks it's really really good
i'm really excited pete peratta is going
to be here he's an amazing drummer super
excited to have him and we're getting
the big crew we're getting the fog
machine and we're filming a music video
oh it's going to come out on saturday in
a haunted house sweatpants it is going
to get hot there's no air conditioning
perfect yeah it's like an old 1800s far
like farmhouse
wow and we filmed the first part of it
in disrepair and now it's been partially
renovated for this second half of the
video let's get a huge fan we'll set up
well we're gonna get on us while we're
playing we're gonna get a couple of
portable air conditioner units so that
we can film this because it's gonna be
an all-day thing we gotta we gotta move
stuff around and play the song like ten
times but i'm really excited for this
and then uh we the ad run we have in
times square it's going up probably
august 21st vid images from the video
it's gonna be really amazing super
excited for this and uh good music
really great music carter banks is an
amazing genius music producer so we're
really excited for this
really excited let's grab some more
super chats
type 54 black star says tried to vote
yesterday in az as a libertarian and was
only able to vote for the single
libertarian running why am i forced to
vote per party tim are still planning on
getting your ffl
i mean at some point it would be nice to
get an ffl luke wanted to buy one i
don't know if i can pull that off what's
ffl uh firearm federal firearms license
i think that's what it stands for you
have to buy it you register a business
and then you go through the hoops and
then you can have a license for selling
guns oh interesting yeah and federal
firearms license yeah depending on what
tier it is or however
like there you can you can have
suppressors and short barrel rifles and
all these crazy nfa items and then
there's even an application to apply for
a nuclear weapon or like robot
robot autonomous autonomous yeah i mean
probably i mean it'd be really cool a
bunch of those robots just want that dog
yeah i mean i'm done i'm freaked out by
them you've seen those bosses videos we
were driving by there uh going to see
family and i was like oh my goodness
look it's boston dynamics terrifying
did you see the video where it has the
mounted machine or semi-automatic yeah
yeah i think it's full all right let's
grab let's grab one more here we got
mike derusha he says
99.99 says tim won't talk about how
brave new world is happening in real
time sexualized kids world government
eternal youth government mandated drugs
changed my mind well we have talked
about that quite a bit the only thing is
we like to
point to luke rodkowski's shirt where it
shows all of the dystopian novels as a
venn diagram and the middle says you are
here
because it's not just brave new world
it's a little bit of everything so my
friends if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show if you
really like it and head over to
timcast.com sign up to become a member
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show talking about some some
we'll call spicy topics
that uh probably not family friendly
we'll put it that way you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
personally at tim cast libby you want to
shout anything out yeah i want to shout
out the postmillennial.com you should
come check us out i'm at twitter
um
oh and it's just my name at libby emmons
you can also come check out
humanevents.com we're doing a lot of
really interesting op-eds over there
that i've been loving loving seeing that
work
and that's pretty much yeah that's it
that's my whole shout out
i'm hannah claire brimlow i'm gonna plug
timcast.com i'm there five times a day
you can click on the read tab and see
not just me but the rest of the news
team hard at work and i'm on instagram
at hannah claire.b it's a good week you
guys get involved get engaged this one's
for you i'm ian crossland you can follow
me in crossland.net uh get in touch with
me on social media through there if
you'd like to also
nail that like button if you haven't
done it yet and click the bell yeah ding
that bell so you get notifications when
the show goes live and i'll see you next
time
and thanks for watching
we'll see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out
you